m
françois
boulot bonjour est ce que on vous reçoit
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle singer view une chaîne
internet fai indépendante est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succinctement
je m'appelle françoise et 32 au barreau
de rouen depuis sept ans et je suis
porte parole des jeunes aaron hill vous
êtes spécialisé en droit pénal en rond
des influx andrew duc ou alors j'ai pas
de certificat de spécialisation donc je
veux pas dire spécialisé puisque
déontologiquement il faudra un
certificat mais je pratique le droit du
travail principalement est également le
droit bancaire le droit de la
consommation droit commercial ça
vous appris comment vous retrouvez avec
le gilet jaune très
simplement ça faisait plusieurs années
que je m'étais vraiment intéressé à la
politique et j'avais dis pour ma part à
mon entourage que macro élus six mois
plus tard la france serait dans la rue
je me suis trompé d'un an mais quand
j'ai vu effectivement le mouvement à
prendre de l'ampleur avant même le 17
novembre j'ai eu l'intuition également
peut-être l'espoir que la mobilisation
elle est massive et que ça allait très
largement dépassé le cadre de
l'augmentation de la taxe sur le
carburant et donc je me suis investi dès
le 17 novembre en allant sur les sur les
points de blocage pour aller discuter
avec les gens et j'ai compris
effectivement que les gens allaient
rester là et qu'ils avaient la prison
science alors que depuis des années ils
se sentaient isolés et impuissants et
résignés vous avez pris conscience de
leur force collective et qu' il allait
désormais être déterminé à relever la
tête pour essayer de reprendre en main
leur destin
rappelez nous rappeler nous un petit peu
l'historicité du mouvement des gilets
jaunes c'est parti à partir de quoi
c'est parti pour quoi
initialement la contestation est partie
de la décision du gouvernement
d'augmenter la taxe sur les carburants
et évidemment c'est la cité suscité une
très grande colère de personnes qui sont
obligés de prendre leur voiture tout
simplement pour aller travailler et qui
déjà été dans des situations financières
extrêmement délicate et augmenter comme
ça un cours de la vie quotidienne qui
est extrêmement important pour eux a
suscité cette colère il ya eu cette
vidéo initialement de jacqueline moreau
qui a fait un peu le buzz sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis les médias se
sont emparés emparé de cette question là
on donnait la parole notamment à
jacqueline mots j'avoue pour ma part que
j'étais un peu surpris d'ailleurs que
les médias relais autant ce mouvement et
je crois qu'il n'avait pas bien compris
en fait saisie que le moment elle est
très largement les dépasser et que ça
allait constituer une une contestation
sociale est profondément populaire de
très grande ampleur voilà ce qui était
l'origine du mouvement et je crois que
c'est le monstre a un peu échappé aux
médias et il s'attendait peut-être pas à
ce qu'il y ait autant de monde le samedi
et surtout je pense qu'il n'avait pas
prévu que ça ne s'arrêterait pas au
samedi 17 novembre 2018 et que ça allait
continuer et quand je suis retourné dès
le lendemain donc le 18 novembre sur
l'un des ronds-points on parlait déjà de
révolution à dire que les gens en 24
heures il avait déjà fait la passerelle
entre la contestation avec toi sur le
tard sur le carburant à on va
révolutionner la politique dans notre
pays et il faut désormais enfin que nos
gouvernants et bien servent le peuple et
non plus les intérêts de quelques
privilégiés
est ce que vous pouvez me dire la
différence entre une révolte est une
révolution
je dirais simplement que la révolte
c'est une mobilisation de masse pour
contester une politique en place la
révolution c'est quand elle aboutit elle
aboutit a effectivement un changement
profond de la politique et des
institutions du fonctionnement des
institutions dans un pays vous
qualifierez comment le mouvement des
jeunes sont un mouvement de révolte
c'est un mouvement de révolution c'est
un mouvement de foule aujourd'hui c'est
une révolte c'est l'histoire qui le dira
mais aujourd'hui c'est une révolte mais
si le mouvement vient à gagner et a
effectivement arrivé à impulser un
profond changement dans la politique du
pays alors je pense qu'on pourra parler
de révolution si demain notamment le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne était
effectivement mis en oeuvre alors on
aurait révolutionner en grande partie
nos institutions et redonner un pouvoir
d'intervention directe du peuple dans la
démocratie
évidemment ce le fonctionnement serait
alors bien différent de ce qu'on peut
connaître depuis des années et des
années qui
le qu'est ce qui vous a agi en tant que
porte-parole des jaunes et comment ça
s'est passé très
simplement moi j'allais donc sur les sur
le rond-point de la motte initialement à
rouen il ya trois gros ronds points à
rouen il y en avait un à barentin
également mais il y en a trois rois j'y
allais tous les jours et au bout d'une
dizaine de jours il ya eu une réunion
publique qui a été organisée sur un
parking d'une zone commerciale qui
réunissait donc différents ronds-points
de roi et ses alentours et j'ai eu
l'occasion donc de prendre la parole et
de d'exprimer qu'elle était à mon avis
les revendications qui fédérer
l'ensemble du mouvement d'exprimer quel
était l'objectif du mouvement et puis
par quelle stratégie on pouvait essayer
d'y arriver donc j'essaie d'avoir un
discours structurants et c'est cette
réunion qui à la suite de cette réunion
que les personnes durant point de la
menthe du rond-point de la motte monde
demande effectivement d'être porte
parole auprès des médias et puis ensuite
on fait la même demande le rond-point
des vaches et le rond-point du zénith
pour que je m'exprime dans les médias et
suivant une mission que j'avais de toute
façon moi indiqué c'est à dire que on
était à l'époque où le gouvernement
expliquait que en fait il n'avait qu'une
volonté qui était celle de dialoguer de
négocier mais malheureusement il n'y
avait pas de représentants dans le
mouvement donc il pouvait pas dialoguer
et donc bon on avait bien compris que
c'était un enfumage et que ces gens là
voulaient absolument pas dialoguer ou
négocier et donc j'avais indiqué aux
gens mais en fait c'est ce qu'il
faudrait c'est peut-être des messages et
des gens qui auraient uniquement pour
mission de porter la parole dans les
médias parce qu'il ya évidemment un
rapport de force au niveau de la
communication qui se joue
on le voit aujourd'hui avec les
tentatives pour discréditer le mouvement
par toutes les manières possibles la
violence le racisme d'antisémitisme mais
et donc on m'a demandé de mettre par
écrit un mandat et donc gg c'est ce que
c'est ce que j'ai fais donc vous avez
deux lignes dans mon mandat 1 je suis
désignée porte parole et 2 ma mission
donc ça ne consiste pas dans le fait de
dialoguer négocier avec le pouvoir
exécutif mais en revanche de défendre
dans les médias le mouvement et ses
revendications et donc les gens ont
signé ces mandats sur les sur les trois
ronds points et c'est comme ça que je
suis devenu le porte parole à rouen
c'est une vision de galles non pas du
tout ça avec une valeur légale c'est une
valeur uniquement moral j'avais indiqué
aux gens notamment
que si
ça avait une valeur juridique de toute
façon comme il n'ya pas de durée
déterminée à ce mandat l'engagement
perpétuelle endroit ça n'existe pas et
donc quand vous avez un engagement qui
est à durée indéterminée vous pouvez y
mettre fin à tout moment et donc je leur
avais dit bon ça n'a pas de valeur
légale ça n'a qu'une valeur morale de
légitimité auprès des médias mais
personne combien de personnes vont
signer environ 200 au total sur les
trois ronds points en fait ce sont les
laits permanent des ronds points c'est
ce qui était vraiment présent
physiquement sur les ronds-points au
quotidien qu'ils ont signés qui ont
signé six mois le spectre des personnes
qui ce qui s'était retrouvée où ils se
retrouvent encore sur ces ronds-points
c'est quel type de personne c'est du cap
supérieur s'est découvert
en grande majorité c'est quand même vous
trouvez des retraités d'un qui sont
plutôt en difficulté financière vous
trouvez des gens qui sont au chômage
mais vous trouvez également des salariés
qui vivent la précarité ne serait ce
qu'avec la réforme du code du travail
qui est intervenue un mois d'octobre
2010 est et qui a laminé ce qu'on
appelle le contrat à durée indéterminée
puisque désormais vous avez un barème
d'indemnisation qui est prévu et donc on
assiste à des licenciements sans motif
simplement parce que l'employeur c'est
qu'au pire il sera condamné à une une
seulement à titre de dommages et
intérêts qui est très modique
donc ces gens là vivent ça la précarité
donc la peur derrière la perte de
l'emploi battre perdre leur logement ou
de se faire poursuivre par la banque sur
leurs crédits et par rapport à leur
crédit immobilier bon et puis vous avez
également quelques
agriculteurs pas beaucoup mais il y en a
ou agriculteurs reconverti d'ailleurs
parce qu'ils n'arrivaient plus à vivre
de leur travail et vous avez également
quelques chefs de pme mais c'est vrai
que là la plupart des gens qui sont
concrètement physiquement mobilisés ce
sont plutôt des gens qui vivent vraiment
une grande précarité précarité sur le
plan financier alors les revendications
de ces de ces personnes ça consiste en
quoi qu'est ce qu'ils demandent très
simplement vous avez un premier type de
revendications qui tient au fond de la
politique et c'est la vente et ces gens
là que la politique serbe désormais 99 %
de la population et non plus les 1% les
plus riches et ensuite quand vous avez
ce fil conducteur à l'esprit vous
comprenez l'ensemble des revendications
catégorielles qui se sont exprimées au
travers des différents cahiers de
doléances qui y ont fleuri sur
l'ensemble du territoire c'est
l'augmentation du smic et plus
généralement les augmentations de
salaires c'est la revalorisation du
minimum vieillesse et de l'allocation
adulte handicapé c'est la réindexation
des retraites et des allocations
familiales sur l'inflation c'est le
dégel du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires c'est la suppression de
la tva sur les produits de première
nécessité compensée par une augmentation
d'un pour cent sur les produits de luxe
bon vous voyez des des revendications
qui touche concrètement la vie des gens
et des difficultés et des différentes
catégories de la population et pour
financer tout cela la première des
choses c'est de remettre en cause les
dispositifs fiscaux injuste qui ont été
adoptées au début du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron qui sont au bénéfice d
un pour cent des 0 1% les plus riches
donc c'est la réforme de l'isf f c'est
la flat tax c'est l'exil taxes etc le
cic e et l'ensemble de ces dispositifs
fiscaux on pourra revenir si vous voulez
sur des explications techniques mais au
bénéfice d un avoir des 0 1% les plus
riches c'est 30 milliards d'euros par an
donc cela la première chose c'est déjà
de remettre en cause ces dispositifs
pour redonner est bien dû ce qu'on
appelle du pouvoir d'achat en fait c'est
une dignité que les gens demandent de
pouvoir vivre de leur travail de pouvoir
vivre dignement leur travail et puis
vous avez la deuxième revendre type de
revendications qui est d'ordre
institutionnel c'est la volonté pour le
peuple de pouvoir intervenir directement
dans la démocratie c'est donc ce qu'on
appelle le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne est en fait c c'est l'idée que
mais depuis 40 ou 45 ans non gouvernance
n'ont pas fait leur travail en tout cas
ils ont cherché tout sauf la poursuite
de l'intérêt général et que dans la
mesure où ils n'ont pas su faire le
travail mais maintenant on va le faire à
leur place et a priori on pourra pas
faire pire on
pourra pas faire plus donc vous avez
chiffré ça à peu près à 30 milliards
pour
redistribuer ça auprès des salariés les
plus précaires ou auprès des plus
précaires
et comme une personne au smic en france
deux
personnes au smic je ne serai pas vous
dire combien il y en a il ya vous avez
un salaire médian qui à 1700 euros par
mois donc ça donne quand même une bonne
idée vu que le smic et à 1500 euros brut
par mois 1200 euros nets à peu près ça
donne une bonne idée du nomes quand même
de personnes qui peuvent être tout ce
mic pas au smic pardon et vous avez de
toute façon neuf millions de personnes
qui vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté et
5 millions de chômeurs dont globalement
on peut dire qu'il ya 4 millions de
personnes qui sont sous le seuil de
pauvreté donc avec moins de 1000 euros
par mois donc voyez si vous avez
peut-être 30 millions d'actifs à peu
près on vous fait un calcul mais on est
on divise par deux déjà et on a quand
même un bon paquet de personnes qui sont
au smic ou qui n'ont pas beaucoup plus
donc réévaluer le spx ça
ça [grognement]
veut dire augmenter beaucoup de
personnes est ce que l'état a les moyens
de
sa en dehors des 30 milliards du cic et
des 250
milliards de d'évasion fiscale commise
d'évasion fiscale s'étaient alors c'est
c'était 80 à 100 milliards et le il ya
eu un dernier rapport à qui et qui est
sorti et on serait peut-être même à 120
milliards par an d'évasion fiscale mais
il est évident que les dispositifs
fiscaux hauteur 30 milliards c'est pas
c'est pas tout à fait suffisant mais ce
serait déjà un début est ce qu'on dit
notamment c'est sur le cic eux donc qui
va coûter la 40 milliards par an enfin
sur l'année 2019 à l'état il ya la
moitié qui est capté par les plus
grandes entreprises du pays donc le cac
40 est ce que nous disons c'est que
cac40 distribuer 47 milliards de
dividendes en 2017 ces 57 milliards en
2018 donc on est deux on le record en
france de distribution de dividendes en
europe et donc ces entreprises on
constate bien que depuis des années elle
ne crée pas d'emplois au contraire elles
ne font que délocaliser donc l on
supprime des emplois donc là le seul à
seul l'utilisation qui est faite de
cette aide fiscale c'est d'augmenter la
distribution de dividendes donc quand
certains hommes politiques disent que le
cic où ça a permis de maintenir quelques
entreprises a flu parce que vous
entendez cet argument là maintenant
parce que de toute façon il est
contredit par le rapport de francs
stratégie qui a indiqué que le
dispositif du cic est là sur les
premières années de son application a
permis de créer ou de sauvegarder cent
mille emplois et en plus c'est une
hypothèse qui n'est pas tout à fait tout
pas tout à fait vérifié c'est à dire que
ça procède pas d'une étude scientifique
et c'est donc plutôt une estimation de
ce que ça aurait donc créés ou
sauvegardés donc à supposer meilleure
hypothèse que ça ait créé 100 mille
emplois ça veut dire que ont versé 20
milliards par an pour 100 mille emplois
ça veut dire qu'un emplois par an ça
coûte 200 mille euros il ya peut-être
une possibilité d'utiliser le
l'argent d'une manière un peu plus
efficace parce qu'avec deux cent mille
euros on peut peut-être arriver à
financer un peu plus que un emploi créé
donc c'est en partie dû au fait que
quand cette aide est captée par les plus
grandes entreprises de ce pays qui ne
finit elle sert à la distribution de
dividendes aux actionnaires et que ses
actionnaires la ne réinvestissent pas
leur argent dans l'économie réelle le
problème aujourd'hui en fait c'est que
ces gens on capte tellement d'argent que
une fois qu'ils ont achetés
schématiquement un yacht cinq villas et
dix voitures de luxe il n'y a pas
d'autres richesses matérielles d'un a
dit souhaiter société aujourd'hui à
consommer et ils vont donc placer cet
argent dans la sphère financière et ça
va servir à la spéculation mais ça ne
permet pas l'investissement dans
l'économie réelle le pouvoir le pouvoir
à ce que si ce chiffre parce
que 3 août kate villa de
la farine et on en passe est-ce que vous
avez mis votre prisme de lecture sous
sur l'aspect un peu mégalomane un peu de
pouvoir un peu de guerre économique et
mélangez tout ça et peut-être mais le
pouvoir ça me paraît pas être un
objectif vertueux je pense que la
question de l'accumulation des richesses
elle devient immoral c'est à dire que
vous ne pouvez pas vivre dans un pays
qui aient accumulé vous à titre
personnel une richesse 10 100 1000 fois
supérieur à vos besoins et à vos besoins
premiers et alors que dans le pays vous
avez neuf millions de personnes qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté vous
avez 140000 sdf à un moment donné quand
vert pour vous c'est pathologique pour
vous c'est un manque d'empathie c'est
une déconnexion c'est quoi
peut-être
que effectivement il ya il ya un aspect
pathologique peut-être que ces gens ce
qu'en dira ce se persuade que ils sont
effectivement les élites de la nation et
que c'est eux qui permettent de faire
fonctionner l'économie qu'ils ont créé
des richesses et de la valeur bon on
sait quand même que parmi les 40 je
crois milliardaire français on sait que
la moitié sont des rentiers donc ils
sont pas partis de rien avec sont des
héritiers de leurs pères ou leurs grands
pères qui ont construit des grandes
fortunes donc pourquoi ils font ça je ne
sais pas je crois que de toute façon on
à faire une classe qui est totalement
dans le déni qui résonnent comme des
machines qui effectivement n'a aucune
empathie qui de toute façon ne voit pas
la misère et ne veut pas la voir et vit
dans des endroits où ils ne sont jamais
confrontés à cette misère aux classes
populaires à ceux qui dans notre pays
aujourd'hui sont obligés de faire les
poubelles pour manger enfin je veux dire
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut pas
tolérer j'imagine quand même que s'il
assistait effectivement à une scène
pareille il serait quand même bouleversé
et il aurait honte les horaires de de
consommer que comme ils le font et
d'accumuler autant de richesses mais ils
n'en n'ont pas l'occasion parce que ils
vivent entre eux ils voyagent dans des
endroits entre eux et finalement ils ont
jamais l'occasion et ils ne veulent vous
avez rencontré cette peur classe ou es
ce que vous avez pu voir whisky ou
est-ce qu'ils voyagent et où est-ce qui
vous lisent et voici des choses comme ça
vous les avez rencontré en tant
qu'avocat
moi j'en connais des amis très riches en
volley saint barth moi je n'en connais
aucun personnellement je n'ai jamais
rencontré ce qu'on peut appeler un
oligarque un milliardaire moi j'en
connais pas ce que je sais d'eux c'est
notamment le travail qu'ont pu réaliser
les pinçon charlot et qui ont décrit par
le menu qu'elle était effectivement les
modes de vie de ces personnes et que
comme je disais ils vivent entre eux ils
se reproduisent entre eux et d'organiser
les gars là pour que leurs enfants se
rend compte entre eux et surtout reste
entre alice et cetera les rallyes
exactement les rallyes dès lundi vous
non non non mais j'ai eu des
connaissances un ca pour pour le coup
qui ont pu faire des rallyes mais pour
ma part non non moi je viens pas du tout
je viens pas du tout de ce milieu là
rallye pour résumer autres ig allemand
c'est une soirée de gens de bonne
famille qui se rend compte pour pouvoir
bien
se marier c'est ça voilà ça comment vous
expliquez qu'il ya pas les 4 millions de
pauvres dans les rues qui commence à
faire pour reprendre les mots de juan
branco les faire trembler pourquoi ils
sont pas dans le russe et de la
résignation ccc
quoi je
crois qu'il ya quand même un travail
idéologique depuis 40 ou 45 ans pour
empoisonner les esprits 1 parce qu'on
appelle l'idéologie dominante qui est
l'idéologie néolibérale et que
finalement cette
idéologie constitue l'horizon
indépassable qu'on ne peut pas faire
autrement que le cadre qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui notamment le cadre
économique s'impose à nous et on ne peut
pas aller dans une autre direction et
donc il ya effectivement de la
résignation qui est qui et qui ressort
de ce la table depuis des années des
années le débat économique il est
totalement verrouillé et on vous
explique donc de toutes façons on ne
peut pas faire autrement que faire la
croissance alors que vous avez un gâteau
et on nous explique on ne peut pas
changer la clé de répartition de ce
gâteau parce que si vous tentez de la
changer et pour essayer de prendre
peut-être d'imposer un petit peu plus
les très riches ils vont partir du pays
et donc la l'économie va s'effondrer
donc on vous dit il faut on peut pas
changer clé de répartition va donc il
faut augmenter le gâteau la seule
manière d'aider les pauvres de sortir
l'époque de leur pauvreté c'est
d'augmenter le gâteau mais pour y
arriver on prend déjà on nous explique
que les bonnes solutions c'est déjà de
donner encore plus à ceux qui ont déjà
beaucoup trop pour qu'on arrive à faire
la croissance et augmenter le gâteau ce
qui est ce qui fait qu'en fait on a deux
impasses la première à passer les
politiques sévères qu'en faisant ça on
accroissent encore et de manière
exponentielle on constate les inégalités
et donc évidemment plus vous accroissez
les inégalités et plus vous crée des
tensions sur le plan social et plus vous
risquez d'aller vers des crises
politiques et in fine et une fille née
vers potentiellement la guerre civile et
la deuxième un passe évidemment absolue
incontestable c'est l'impasse écologique
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on sait très bien
que notre modèle fondé depuis des années
sur la croissance ne peut plus prospérer
puisque aujourd'hui nos ressources sont
limitées donc nous ne pouvons plus viser
la croissance ne pouvons plus visés
l'augmentation du gâteau et à partir du
moment où vous avez ce constat là à
l'esprit la seule solution ça va être de
changer de la clé de répartition
pourquoi
les 4 millions sont pas dans les rues
bien par le travail de sape idéologique
fait par les politiques les médias ou le
comme vous le décrivez le modèle
néolibéral istres pourquoi je
crois vraiment que il
ya la résignation qui peut tenir à
l'aspect idéologique et puis après vous
avez comment dirais-je une résignation
qui tient au fait que au comportement en
fait de nos gouvernants qui de toute
façon on entend de rien son saut on le
voit entre le 17 novembre et aujourd'hui
il ya quand même moins de monde mobilisé
bon en partie parce qu'il ya eu des
violences de les manifestations et que
donc on a tout fait pour effrayer les
gens et qu'ils rentrent chez eux c'est
une première explication
et puis également parce que toute façon
les gens voient qu en fait nos
gouvernants ne les entendent pas donc
ils se lisent à quoi bon je pense
vraiment qu'il ya tombe il tombe dans le
misérabilisme de l'impuissance ouais
ouais je pense que c'est ça
et non plus quoi avec salon l'idée
c'est d'essayer de les réveiller donc
ces deux-là expliqué qu'en réalité il ya
des solutions très simples demain pour
améliorer déjà leur quotidien donc c'est
donner les clefs sur les fameux
dispositifs fiscaux les 30 milliards et
puis c'est après d'élargir encore le le
niveau de conscience on pourrait aller
chercher l'argent effectivement sur les
intérêts de la dette publique qui coûte
40 milliards par an on peut aller
chercher l'évasion fiscale dans tout le
monde voit bien que nos gouvernants ne
font absolument rien pour pour traiter
cette question majeure qui si elle était
traitée demain nous permettrait est bien
de ne plus être en déficit puisque le
défi c'était est à 75 milliards par an
revenons
un peu sur les violences policières pour
vous pour vous ça a été fait à dessein
pour décourager les gens mais bien sûr
ça c'est une absolue certitude en fait
depuis le début du mouvement au
début il était sur les ronds points il y
avait des barrages et blocages mais
c'était plutôt du filtrage et il ya une
petite tolérance pendant quelques jours
par le gouvernement et puis très vite
ils ont compris que la le mouvement
était en train de s'enraciner que les
gens faisaient des cabanes etc ils
s'étaient organisés et que s'y laisser
ça comme ça s était pas prêt de
s'arrêter et donc les ordres ont été
donnés aux forces de l'ordre pour aller
déloger systématiquement les rampants et
donc vous avez des ronds points qui ont
été délogés 20 25 30 fois par les forces
de l'ordre il y en a qui a été délogé
chez nous le rond-point des vaches c'est
une journée ils sont venus quatre fois
dans la même journée pour déloger et à
chaque fois c'était destruction de la
des cabanes qui pouvait être montés ont
jeté les provisions à la poubelle et ça
avait évidemment et pour objectif de
briser psychologiquement les gens et de
les faire rentrer chez eux tout
simplement et puis ensuite comme les
gens ne pouvaient plus mobilisés sur les
ronds points c'est la raison pour
laquelle le mouvement a buté dans son
action et que sont survenus les
manifestations du samedi et là on a tout
de suite vu qu'il y avait des stratégies
de mme interne l'ordre qui étaient tout
à fait inédite
on a eu le dire j'ai le souvenir des
l'acte 2 je crois à paris que les
manifestants dès 8h30 étaient déjà
menacés et était déjà en train de se
faire gazer par par les forces de
l'ordre donc quand dès 8h30 ou neuf
heures du matin vous fait gazer il est
évident que ça va pas bien se passer
parce que les gens vont bien sûr essayer
de chercher à sortir et à se libérer des
gaz qui qui leur sont envoyées et je
crois même d'ailleurs qu'ils les forces
de l'ordre je n'imagine pas ne savent
pas pour ceux qui sont dans les cordes
en de blocage il s'imagine pas un seul
instant en fait tout est bloqué il ya
que ceux qui sont qui supervise les
opérations sur le terrain qu'ils savent
qu'ils ont tout bloqué donc il ya ça il
ya eu ensuite le le comportement j'irai
dans les paroles qui ont été prononcées
ou celles qui ne l'ont pas été vous avez
depuis
le début un président la république et
le gouvernement qui n'ont pas eu un mot
pour tous les manifestants qui ont été
blessés ils n'ont pas eu un mot pour
condamner les dérives individuelles
quand même nombreuses de la part des
policiers et donc ils ont laissé en
réalité une impunité totale aux
forces de l'ordre alors moi je soutiens
les forces de l'ordre dans leur très
grande majorité mais il faut condamner
les comportements individuels qui sont
totalement d'evian et illégaux sauf que
ils ne l'ont jamais fait et pire ils ont
qualifié les gilets jaunes de foule
haineuse d'agitateurs de s'édifier de
séditieux on a vraiment le sentiment que
tout a été fait pour jeter de l'huile
sur le feu et pour monter au maximum le
climat de tension dans le pays créée
favoriser au maximum les violences et
pour in fine et effrayer les gens et que
le mouvement soit étouffée parce que les
gens aient bien
n'irai plus manifestée par peur d'être
blessés mutilés ou éborgné c'est pour
vous des techniques de contre
insurrection oui bien sûr alors on voit
très clairement qu'il ya une ces gens là
sont sûrs d'eux mêmes sont sûrs de leur
fait ils sont persuadés d'avoir raison
il n'écoute personne et ils appliquent
un pour le programme dont ils se disent
que ça fait 30 ans de toute façon qu'on
aurait dû à mettre en place ces
solutions lire toutes les réformes sont
dans les cartons de bercy depuis des
années et des années et ils se disent
les précédents n'ont jamais eu le
courage de le faire donc nous on va y
aller en mode bulldozer et donc c'est ce
qu'ils font il n'écoute personne et donc
il voit en fait les gilet jaune comme la
foule haineuse comme les gueux qui sont
des abrutis qui ne comprennent rien et
donc nous on sait mieux que et donc on
va faire ce dont on est sûr que c'est
c'est bon pour le pays revenant
sur l'épisode du discrédit jeté par le
gouvernement sur le gilet jaune en
prenant des actes pendant les
manifestations de type antisémite
raciste violent et
j'en passe comme vous avez entendu ça ça
ça vous a surpris pas surpris est ce que
c'est le reflet du mouvement des gilet
jaune est ce que c'est la
haine qui se matérialise qui cherchent
des coupables
alors j'aime
bien la fin de votre question
effectivement la haine qui se
matérialise et qui cherchent des
coupables je crois qu'effectivement il
ya un réflexe en fait derrière le
gouvernement ou le traitement médiatique
ne les médias traditionnels de se jeter
effectivement sur les quelques faits
divers tout à fait condamnable pour
jeter le discrédit sur l'ensemble du
mouvement on y assister
bien sûr ces derniers jours avec
vraiment là une propagande extrêmement
puissante pour qualifier le mouvement d'
antisémite mais on avait déjà eu ça au
tout début du mouvement je me souviens
très bien qu'il y avait déjà eu un fait
divers sur un homophobe sur une histoire
de caravanes de migrants sur un fait
aussi antisémite enfin dès le début en
fait on a eu sa on assiste en fait un
réflexe de classe qui a très peur des
classes populaires qu'ils ne connaissent
pas et qu'il méprise et donc qu'ils vont
se jeter sur le moindre fait divers
condamnable pour essayer de de
discréditer le mouvement moi ce qui me
je trouve assez singulier et ce qui
témoigne en fait de l'âme à noter
malhonnêteté intellectuelle de ces gens
là c'est qu'à titre personnel j'ai donc
reçu 200 signatures pour être porte
parole j'ai aujourd'hui un peu plus de
60000 personnes qui me soutiennent sur
sur la page facebook et on m'a dit très
souvent mais vous n'êtes pas légitime
vous n'avez pas été mandatés par
l'ensemble du mouvement c'est vrai tout
à fait bref je pas été mandatés par
l'ensemble du mouvement mais alors
expliquez-moi pourquoi quand vous avez
trois gugusses qui vont prononcer des
insultes antisémites contre telle ou
telle personne alors là il n'y a pas de
difficultés ça rend l'ensemble du
mouvement anti sémite il ya évidemment
la un amalgame qui est fait dans un cas
et pas dans l'autre et ça révèle une
malhonnêteté intellectuelle est en fait
un mépris de classe et la volonté par
dessus tout d'étouffer le mouvement est
ce que ne comprennent pas ces gens là
c'est que ce serait la pire des choses
que demain le mouvement soit étouffée
parce que la colère est évidemment ne
serait pas apaisé et donc si vous
reposer le couvercle de force vous vous
exposez à ce que demain la colère et
expose une manière encore plus puissante
de manière encore plus violente
vous êtes fichier ne
s'est pas fait la demande pour savoir
non vous et écoutez je
sais pas j'ai vu qu' il y avait a priori
150g les jeunes qui étaient écoutés donc
je
me dis qu'à priori il ya des choses pour
que je le sois au après il ya une
protection particulière liée à mon
statut d'avocat et des garde-fous en
principe bon mais je ne sais pas nous
avons cherché à savoir non mais j'essaie
de prendre certaines
précautions mais après on fait pour
savoir très franchement je n'ai pas
l'idée mais ce que je suis assez prudent
déjà moi je ne fais que des actions
pacifiques depuis le début j'ai jamais
appelé à des actions illégales donc je
suis dans une action qui je n'ai rien à
me reprocher que vous appelez à la
destitution du président de la
république ça
peut être considérée comme une attaque
frontale directe
envers les institutions dont moi j'ai
jamais appelé à la destitution du
président de la république moi j'ai
toujours dit la chose suivante
la balle est dans le camp du pouvoir
exécutif et par conséquent de deux
choses l'une soit il change radicalement
de politique ce qui implique un virage à
180 degrés soit nous retournons aux
urnes est donc là il a encore le choix
c'est à dire que ce soit il dissout
l'assemblée nationale soit ils
démissionnent purement et simplement
soit il fait un référendum en engageant
son mandat à l'image de ce que faisait
le général de gaulle quand il était
président voilà la balle est dans le
camp de l'exécutif est
ce qu'on peut parler du souverainisme à
le souverainisme balle évidemment c'est
un un mot aujourd'hui qui est diabolisé
alors que si vous êtes souverainiste
vous êtes populiste si vous êtes
populiste vous êtes fasciste et on
essaye de faire confond le souverainisme
avec le nationalisme et ce sont des mots
aujourd'hui utilisée de manière
péjorative pour disqualifier les gens ce
qui est quand même très curieux parce
que en réalité le général de gaulle
notamment à disait que le souverainisme
pour nous on fonds intégralement avec la
démocratie et pour une raison très
simple c'est que l'on nous explique que
nous sommes donc en démocratie donc
c'est le peuple qui a le pouvoir et le
peuple souverain délègue donc sa
puissance à l'état est censé dont
incarner la puissance souveraine du
peuple ça veut donc dire qu'il faut que
l'état soit souverain et qu'il est
l'ensemble des prérogatives à sa
disposition et aujourd'hui il est
évident que on a consenti de telle
délégation de pouvoir à l'union
européenne est dans le cadre des traités
européens que nous ne sommes plus
maîtres de notre politique économique et
c'est notamment le fait il ya trois
raisons principales c'est que nous ne
sommes plus maîtres de notre politique
budgétaire nous ne sommes plus maîtres
de notre politique monétaire et nous ne
sommes plus maîtres de notre politique
commerciale je sais pas s'il est si vous
voulez que je développe les trois les
trois sujets sur l'aspect budgétaire
c'est le fameux pacte de stabilité
budgétaire européen et la règle des 3%
de déficit défier d'europe ne doit pas
dépasser 3% du pib donc très bien et
donc on nous expose cette règle commune
règles de saine gestion budgétaire ce
qui est quand même un club donc ça veut
dire qu'on a le droit de faire du
déficit je rappelle que le déficit doit
se distinguer de la dette parce que
souvent sur les plateaux de télévision
vous avez des gens qui confondent les
deux le déficit c'est la balance entre
les recettes et les dépenses sur une
année bon donc si vous avez le droit de
faire des déficits d'année en année
quand
bien même vous b seriez le déficit vous
êtes toujours en déficit ça veut dire
donc que vous augmentez la dette d'année
en année et ça fait effectivement depuis
je crois 74 ou 75 que chaque année nous
avons augmenté la dette puisque nous
adoptons systématiquement des budgets en
déficit c'est eux qui veulent oui oui
peut-être peut-être que ça peut
s'appeler de la cavalerie mais surtout
c'est cool qu'eva joly la
cavalerie c'est de dépenser l'argent
qu'on n'a pas et de aurait emprunté
systématiquement pour pour dépenser
l'argent qu'on n'a pas c'est de
subornation but
[grognement]
la dette on fait plein de promesses on
engage beaucoup plus de gens pour garder
leur vote aux choux je dirais que c'est
pire que la subornation de vote parce
que on constate que malgré les déficits
concrets de ces gens ils sont dans la
misère donc ça sert même pas un pou yo
de dingue voilà enfin un pognon de
dingue mais je crois moi ce que je veux
surtout critiqué c'est la logique de
cette règle de gestion de déficit c'est
à dire que 3% pourquoi 3% ça n'a
strictement aucun sens quand vous avez
une entreprise et que vous êtes en
déficit vous avez deux possibilités soit
vous baissez vos charges soit vous
augmentez votre chiffre d'affaires sinon
souvent fermés soit vous déposer le
bilan voilà bon a priori un et a déposé
le bilan c'est un peu compliqué ça
s'appelle un bain est un fouillis voilà
voilà mais bon un état ne disparaît pas
parce que
parce qu'il fait faillite en tout cas
dans l'histoire récente n'y a pas eu ça
ne s'est pas produit et puis de toute
façon sur la question de la dette il
faut bien dire que tous les pays
développés sont en dette donc ça répond
notamment à l'argument qui est toujours
employée d'expliquer la dette par le
fait que la france aurait vécu au dessus
de ses moyens mais alors qui n'a pas
vécu au dessus de ses moyens expliqué
parce que il n'y a pas un seul pays
développés les états unis la chine le
japon même l'allemagne qui nous est
présenté comme les meilleurs comptable
de la planète ils ont des pieds je crois
au taux de 75 % de leur pib donc ils
sont aussi très endetté et en réalité
donc quand vous avez une entreprise soit
vous baisser les charges soit vous
augmentez le chiffre d'affaires baisser
les charges dans un état soit vous
supprimez les gens sains soit vous
baisser la dépense publique non ça ça
résonne c'est ce qu'on fait depuis 30 ou
40 ans sauf qu'aujourd'hui nos services
publics essentiels ceni régalien police
justice santé éducation ils sont à l'os
et vous à des gens qui se suicident et
c'est donc peut-être arrêter le massacre
et alors la tête et s'est trouvé une
autre solution l'autre solution c'est
augmenter le chiffre d'affaires est dans
un état augmenter le chiffre d'affaires
c'est pas très compliqué sur le plan
théorique c'est réduire le chômage et
retrouver le plein emploi si demain vous
remettez au travail des gens qui sont
aujourd'hui inactifs et bien avec
l'argent la valeur créée par leur
travail ils vont avoir un revenu et ceux
revenus lasfar permettent de consommer
sarah permet de payer des impôts et ça
leur permet de cotiser donc vous recréez
des recettes supplémentaires il a créé
un cri du travail on va leur faire faire
quoi casser des cailloux volonté
d'aider des choux sur les ronds-points
ou sur quoi non mais il ya plein de
travail alors évidemment dans les
services publics vous avez les services
à la personne dans les hôpitaux dans la
justice les magistrats croule sous les
dossiers là je vous parle de ce que je
connais mais de plus en pus banon vous
recréez vous remettez au travail et des
gens qui aujourd'hui n'en n'ont pas donc
personne qui peut dix ans france alors
ça dépendra tout le monde en paix il va
la tva mais après si c'est l'impôt sur
le revenu je sais plus je crois qu'il ya
40% je crois ou 50% des gens qui n'en
payent pas j'ai pu exactement les
chiffres en tête mais je crois que c'est
de cet ordre là mais en tout cas tout le
monde le premier impôt c'est la tva et
c'est le premier set le premier poste de
recettes de l'état c'est 120 milliards
par an à peu près sur un budget total de
recettes de l'état de 2 140 milliards
donc c'est la moitié la tva donc tout le
monde contribue à l'impôt via la tva
également via la csg donc tout le monde
en fait payer l'impôt l'impôt serait
venu finalement c'est que 42 milliards
par an donc sur un budget total de 240
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est c'est pas
très important dit s'il sait combien le
lit sf c'est trois points 5,4 milliards
da par an mais
simplement sur l'impôt sur revenu il ya
quand même une chose assez topic c'est
que on vous explique alors j'ai pu
exactement le chiffre en tête mais je
crois que c'est léa % contribuent à
hauteur peut-être de 40% je crois de de
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est de cet ordre
là donc ça veut dire que globalement il
construit autour de 15 milliards par an
alors
on vous dit vous voyez y contribuer mais
d'un autre côté vous avez les intérêts
de la dette publique 40 milliards et eux
ils sont captés par ces fameux 1 ou 0 1%
donc en réalité c'est robin des bois à
l'envers c'est à dire qu'on prend à tout
le monde et puis derrière on avait 40
milliards qui est qui passent dans la
poche de ses plus privilégiés dit
combien vous moi j'ai un revenu de
l'ordre de 4000 euros par mois d'août
avant
impôt sur le revenu
revenons à nos gilet jaune et vous les
sentez comme en ce moment sur le
rond-point des gens qui vous appelle qui
vous envoient des messages sur facebook
vos antennes sur le terrain sans quoi la
résignation défaitisme
la violence ça commence ça commence à
faire des stratégies sas forme ça se
forment politiquement ça essayer de
comprendre le problème où ça
est-ce que avant de répondre à cette
question là vous voulez que je développe
sur les deux autres points sur l'union
européenne c'est fait exprès vous
connaissez le chef du tube - oui vous
savez qu'on fait exprès déconcentrer les
dix questions sorte voilà moi j'essaye
de maintenir le fil donc
sur la sur le déficit les l'idée je suis
ni même sur la question difficile je
n'ai pas terminé c'est que 3 % s'en
moque la question c'est de relancer
l'emploi et donc s'il faut faire 6 ou 7%
de déficit pendant trois quatre ans avec
un plan à dix ans pour recréer du plein
emploi si ça marche pas tant pis et
alors de toute façon la dette qui va
nous envoyer les chars la main c'est
qui va qui va saigner l'emprunt
français sur les marchés financiers ont
augmenté du tout comme si c'est beau sur
goss voilà donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
envie en deuxième point est la politique
monétaire c'est qu'effectivement on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation très
cocasses et singulière où les états donc
en tout cas pour ce qui est pour ceux
qui sont membres de l'union européenne
se sont obliger à emprunter auprès de la
main ne peuvent pas emprunter pardon
auprès de la banque centrale européenne
ou lors de banques centrales nationales
et ce sont obligés emprunter sur les
marchés financiers donc il en résulte de
conséquence c'est que 1 nous payons des
intérêts 40 milliards par an que nous
pourrions ne pas payer et la deuxième
conséquence beaucoup plus vicieuse c'est
que si nous ne menons pas une politique
conforme aux intérêts des marchés
financiers ils ne menacent d'augmenter
nos taux d'intérêt à nous et c'est
effectivement ce qui s'est passé avec la
grèce qui ne voulait qu'ils voulaient
sortir du cadre et qui s'est fait
attaqué de toutes parts pour augmenter
pour augmenter les taux d'intérêt et les
soumettre en fait à la politique de la
troïka
à l'époque qui s'était mise en mouvement
banque centrale commission et
le dernier d'ailleurs c'était je
sais plus la banque mondiale le fmi
j'avais fait steed voilà christine
lagarde donc
il faut évidemment revenir sur ses
règles de fonctionnement de la monnaie
qui qui ont là les conséquences que je
vous indiquais ça nous permettrait de
faire des économies et puis deux surtout
de refaire la politique qu'on souhaite
et donc arrêter de faire la politique
des banques et des actionnaires dans
l'union européenne mais enfin essayer de
faire l'europe sociale qu'on nous a
vendu et puis troisième élément sur
l'union européenne c'est la politique
commerciale c'est le fameux libre
échange et cette folie de nous être mis
en concurrence dans le cadre d'un marché
commun avec les pays de l'est et donc on
assiste à cette absurdité où les
entreprises des pays développés
délocalise dans les pays de l'est parce
que il dit trouve des salaires cinq à
dix fois inférieur et donc ça leur
permet de réduire leurs coûts de
production et donc d'augmenter leurs
marges et puis dans l'autre sens vous
avez les salariés des pays de l'est qui
viennent dans les pays développés via la
directive sur les travailleurs détachés
pourrait gagner mieux leur vie c'est le
déménagement permanent du monde vous
n'avez aucune régulation et au final à
qui profite le crime est toujours aux
mêmes c'est à dire les multinationales
leurs actionnaires et les banques est
donc temps que on n'aura pas réglé ça
tant qu'on aura également ce libre
échange au niveau de la circulation des
capitaux et qu'on ne contrôle pas ces
circulations les flux financiers
extrêmement important qui se produisent
vous aurez aussi également beaucoup de
difficultés à contrôler l'évasion
fiscale qui se fait quand même
aujourd'hui en grande partie au sein
même de l'union européenne
donc on a à peine à comprendre pourquoi
on instaure pas des mécanismes de
contrôle pour lutter effectivement
contre cela et donc quand vous avez tous
amis tabou mis bout-à-bout vous avez les
dispositifs fiscaux 30 milliards par an
les intérêts de la dette 40 milliards
par an et l'évasion fiscale on va dire
100 milliards par an dire que au final
on est à 170 milliards par an qui va
être captées par les plus privilégiés du
pays c'est à dire les 1 ou 0 1% les plus
riches sur un budget total de 240
milliards donc on a quasiment les trois
quarts du budget de l'état qui au final
sont captés par par les plus privilégiés
voilà pourquoi on est dans ce paradoxe
où notre pib augmente chaque année nos
impôts pour nous la classe moyenne au
sens large ne baisse jamais ils
augmentent même plutôt d'année en année
et on nous explique on est toujours en
déficit où va l'argent il va l'argent et
va dans la poche des plus riches pour
hook ou plus open abat
celle qui fonctionne actuellement à
résolument contre c'est une évidence il
va absolument falloir sortir des traités
européens on peut pas rester truc site
bah moi je pense que le fch exit il doit
être envisagée comme ultime recours mais
il doit clairement être envisagée des
rangs ccc
6 est l'ultime recours c'est que à la
fin du fin si on n'a pas réussi à
changer les choses ça qui doit se passer
c'était notamment il y avait eu un
moment donné inclure dans l'europe on la
change ou on la quitte je pense que ce
qui je crois que c'était mélenchon pour
le coup kekilli et qui me disait comme
ça mais je pense que c'est c'est
ce qu'il faut faire c'est à dire que ne
serait ce qu'en termes de stratégie
politique ça me paraît délicat après 40
ans 50 ans de construction européenne
deux en un claquement de doigts dire on
va salut les gars c'était c'était bien
mais maintenant nous nous on parle de
notre côté bon ça me paraît un peu
cavalier et surtout on prend le risque
notamment de se faire attaquer par les
marchés financiers très rapidement on va
avoir des mesures de rétorsion de
l'allemagne enfin je pense que il faut
avoir une véritable stratégie pour
arriver à sortir des traités européens
c'est à dire que on à faire une
construction qui s'est fait petit pas
par petit pas et tout a été fait pour
que justement ce soit impossible
quasiment d'en sortir non le qui vive il
va falloir être stratégique actionner
des leviers de rapport de force il y en
a toute une série vous pouvez commencer
par désobéir au traité à arrêter de
financer le budget de l'union européenne
et puis des amendes ouais et qui va nous
contraindre à les payer parce que quand
vous comme moi nous sommes particulier
c'est l'huissier qui au final saisi vos
comptes ou où l'état parce que il a des
prérogatives exorbitantes de droit
commun qui va nous obliger à payer les
amendes personnes ra sauf à nous envoyer
les chars et a priori dans l'union
européenne je
vois personne qui qui pourrait attaquer
sur le plan militaire
notre pays compte tenu au surplus du
fait qu'on est la seule puissance à
disposer de l'armé nucléaire donc voyez
un an le dernier rapport de force qui
joue assez d'ailleurs c'est jacques
chirac qui avait dit à propos d'un
désaccord au niveau de l'europe ils vont
quand même pas nous envoyer les chars
non que les abandons les paras pas non
plus ça peut être un premier niveau
d'action la désobéissance s'est arrêtée
de contribuer ça peut être on imprime
nous de des billets à strasbourg donc ça
peut être maîtres de la monnaie et donc
évidemment ça plairait pas à l'allemagne
ça peut être également la politique de
la chaise vide et à redire mais nous on
ne va plus au conseil européen et c'est
tant qu' on ne change pas les traiter en
revenant sur le pack de s'inviter
budgétaire les règles de fonctionnement
l'euro et le libre échange généralisé
vous tentez ça à partir du moment où
vous allez commencer à mettre les pieds
dans le plat les plaques tectoniques et
vont commencer à se mettre en mouvement
effectivement nous faut déjà être
préparés être préparés aux attaques des
marchés financiers faut peut-être avoir
noué des alliances là dessus il ya une
théorie assez intéressante d'emmanuel
todd qui explique que peut-être on aura
besoin à ce moment là de s'appuyer sur
washington et d'avoir l'appui des états
unis ça me plaît pas beaucoup sur le
plan géopolitique parce que j'aurais
plutôt la position qui consiste à a
retrouvé la troisième fois la troisième
voie de de gaulle et donc de retrouver
enfin notre indépendance sur plan
géopolitique et de ne pas s'associer aux
guerres
dans lesquels nous n'avons absolument
aucun intérêt et où la france je crois
rayonne beaucoup plus quand les a quand
elle est dans ce rôle de médiateur et
d'essayer d'éviter à tout prix les
conflits armés mais peut-être que de
manière opportune opportune et pour
faire de la realpolitik peut-être qu'on
aura besoin de ça ce que je veux dire
c'est que sortir des traités européens
c'est une question compliquée en termes
de rapport de force et que free exit
article 50 oui juridiquement
effectivement on peut mettre en place
l'article 50 du traité c'est possible
juridiquement mais la question de la
sortie des traités elle dépasse très
largement la question juridique et à des
rapports de force économiques et
financiers qui vont se jouer vous
parlez de rapport de force vous êtes
contre le fait que les gilets jaunes
créé un parti politique alors est-ce que
du coup vous les jours et je veux
répondre sur la question de la
résignation celle
là moi
je crois que en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est qu'à ce stade faire des
listes
une ou des listes gilet jaune aux
élections européennes ça c'est une
erreur absolue première
il vous pointez du doigt madame
levasseur s'est pas spécialement ça la
concerne elle évidemment puisque elle
est allée officiellement que candidate
non dans quel cadre aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas mais bon elle est mais vous
avez d'autres personnes qui sont qui ont
effectivement constituer des listes
gilet jaune aux européennes moi j'ai
toujours dit la même chose c'est une
erreur parce que l'objectif du mouvement
c'est d'obtenir des avancées maintenant
concrètement mais de manière immédiate
or tout le monde sait très bien que le
parlement européen n'a aucun pouvoir il
ne peut pas être à l'initiative des lois
dans l'union européenne c'est la
commission qui décide donc vous avez là
initiative qui s'inscrit en
contradiction avec l'objectif du
mouvement ensuite sur le plan
stratégique en réalité aujourd'hui on
est dans une mobilisation sociale
populaire quittant essayer de nous de
mener le rapport de force politique pour
briser le quinquennat qui est
actuellement en cours c'est à dire
notamment stopper la réforme annoncée du
régime des retraites la réforme du show
de l'assurance chômage les
privatisations qui sont adoptés de
l'aéroport de paris de la française des
jeux bon c'est ça qu'on essaye de faire
donc allé faire une liste ou des listes
dont on sait qu'elles vont affaiblir les
partis d'opposition et qui vont donc
mécaniquement renforcer le parti de la
majorité quand vous êtes dans une
mobilisation qui vise à essayer
justement de contester la politique du
pouvoir exécutif vous n'allez pas
prendre l'initiative qui va
mécaniquement le renforcer dans sur le
plan de la légitimité politique et on
peut compter sur eux s'ils sortent
premiers des urnes aux élections
européennes pour nous expliquer que sar
légitime toute leur politique et qui
sont donc bien fondé à à poursuivre leur
programme et elle est en fait les
réformes qu'ils envisagent qu'ils
envisagent de faire passer et puis
troisième élément c'est
ce sont des initiatives qui sont tout à
fait anti démocratique parce qu'on est
aujourd'hui toulon a compris il ya une
quasi unanimité des gilet jaune qui rose
qui rejette cette question de listes aux
européennes ils n'en veulent pas et donc
je trouve ça assez singulier dans un
mouvement qui se veut horizontal qui
réclame le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne
que des personnes et biens prennent
l'initiative qui est rejeté par la quasi
unanimité des gens qui prétendent qu'ils
prétendent représenter voilà
pour la question aujourd'hui ça me
paraît tout à fait prématuré dans
l'avenir et donc peut-être pour des fins
la question se posera pour des élections
nationales c'est-à-dire dans le pays ces
présidentielles ou législatives
c'est ça qui peut permettre de
d'effectivement changer la politique
dans ce pays c'est à dire prendre le
pouvoir par les institutions et là
notamment vous pourrait enclencher la
stratégie de sortie des traités
européens tels qu'ils existent
aujourd'hui mais là est ce que ce sera
possible en l'état actuel vous est un
mouvement qui a surgi des ronds-points
de l'ensemble du territoire vous
avez des réseaux effectivement les ronds
points ont commencé à se mettre en
réseau mais voyez le temps que ça peut
prendre de créer une coordination au
niveau national donc déjà est ce que ce
sera possible peut-être c'est pas sûr et
puis la question préalable c'est ce que
les gens vont le vouloir et donc en fait
il faudra de toute façon qui est une
délibération collective pour avoir une
vraie légitimité du mouvement politique
qui potentiellement et bien se créerait
sur la base du mouvement qui lutte est
une question précédente la question
pressante c'est la résignation potentiel
des jeunes vous êtes dur avec moi parce
qu'en plus j'ai pas beaucoup dormi cette
nuit mais ça ne fait que commencer donc
[rires]
sur la l'état d'esprit des gens ce qui
est vraiment un cadre important de
comprendre c'est dès le 17 novembre je
vous le disais la révolution dans les
esprits à les fêtes les gens ils ont
décidé de relever la tête ils sont
déterminés c'est à dire que il ya eu
dans les esprits un avant et un après le
17 novembre on ne reviendra pas à l'état
antérieur donc ils sont déterminés
simplement effectivement vous avez des
passes hier tout le monde avait vu
notamment qu au moment des fêtes de fin
d'année entre noël et le nouvel an il
n'y avait plus beaucoup de mobilisations
et puis il ya eu le discours de voeux du
président de la république et alors là
tout le monde est ressortir en trombe
dans les rues parce que foule haineuse
et l'oréal et que je reprends mes
réformes en avant bon ça ça évidemment
énervé tout le monde donc tout le monde
est ressorti et puis là bas tout le
monde est
et est en colère par la propagande
médiatique qui est fait est en fait
contrairement à la petite musique qui
qui
est passé sur un média traditionnel ça
s'essouffle ça s'essouffle parce que
c'est ce qu'on entend depuis le début du
mouvement je veux dire aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus des airs ainsi si on les
écoute et elle avait longtemps qu'il est
mort le mouvement mais en réalité vous
aviez encore plus de personnes samedi
dernier que le samedi précédent donc
vous avez en fait une mobilisation qui
est contrairement à ce que l'on nous
explique n'est pas dans un flot continu
de descente vous avez 1 des rebonds en
fait qui s'opère et vous avez une
oscillation en réalité les
sources c'est les chiffres qui sont
données y compris même par par les
chiffres officiels qui peuvent être
données qui sont tout à fait mineurs et
ça c'est une évidence mais même quand on
regarde cela si on s'y réfère on voit
qu'en réalité on n'a pas une baisse
continue et qu'on a des rebonds mais en
fait les chiffres qu'on peut avoir c'est
déjà les calculs faits par les médias
locaux quand on agrège les chiffres des
médias locaux on trouve des chiffres
bien supérieur aux chiffres officiels
qui sont donnés par le ministère de
l'intérieur et puis il ya également un
incite le nombre jaune qui s'est créé
pour pour calculer effectivement essayé
de trouver un de donner un chiffre qui
qui correspondent le plus proche de la
réalité et on est plutôt autour de cent
mille cent vingt mille personnes
généralement sur sur les samedis donc
tous les sabiha sont venus de personnes
dans les rues ouais sur l'ensemble du
territoire ouais ça fait beaucoup fait
mais de toute façon le mouvement a
jamais été massivement
physiquement mobiliser ce qui fait la
force du mouvement depuis le départ
c'est que vous avez les têtes dures qui
me se mobilisent et qui lâchent rien et
puis en fait ils ont le soutien de 75%
globalement des gens et quand je parle
de 75% c'est le soutien sur la
légitimité du mouvement sur la
légitimité de ses revendications
effectivement on a si vous quand vous
posez tout dépend en fait la main dont
vous posez la question dans les sondages
si la question englobe les modes
d'action vous êtes aujourd'hui plutôt à
50 50 parce que effectivement personne
après si les les violences et et ça tout
le monde déplore les violences donc vous
avez un soutien qui redescend mais quand
on est que sur la légitimité des
revendications là on est à 75 % de
soutien et donc c'est ça en fait qui a
fait sa force c'est que malgré toutes
les stratégies pour essayer de
diaboliser de discréditer le mouvement
le soutien la sympathie qu'on les gens
sur la légitimité des revendications n'a
jamais baissé et ça c'est inédit parce
que ça ne s'était jamais produit lors
des précédentes mobilisations sociales
le traitement médiatique et les
stratégies de comines utile de
communication arrivait toujours à faire
baisser le soutien aux mouvements et
s'était notamment ça a été notamment le
cas lors de la réforme des cheminots on
va parler un peu de dieu hérisser le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne c'est
bien et on va parler du référendum
d'initiative populaire c'est qu'elle
était l'expression du premier ministre
il appelle à faire un référendum de par
référendum un mouvement 2 je sais même
pas ce que c'est à dire ce qu'il a dit
que c'est le hérissé le hérissé
1ère ici ou rien ou danton vous moi
ce que je veux dire un préalable c'est
que le référendum d'initiative citoyenne
c'est derrière concrètement la
possibilité pour le peuple d'intervenir
directement dans la démocratie c'est
important de toujours le définir ça
parce que si on s'en tient aux slogans à
l'éthique est hérissé parce qu'il n'ya
pas de problème et un jour ils vont nous
le faire et on y vont appeler ça le
hérissé mais ça n'aura rien à voir avec
la vérité vous aurez des garde-fous
partout notamment ils nous feront
peut-être quelque chose sur sur le
modèle de ce qu'on a aujourd'hui le
référendum d'initiative partagée ou en
réalité il vous faut je crois 4 millions
et demi de signatures pour pouvoir
déclencher un référendum sauf que il
vous faut aussi le soutien d'un certain
nombre de parlementaires à l'initiative
donc en réalité le peuple ne peut pas
déclenchée seul par lui-même un
référendum ensuite en l'état actuel
leurs affaires même initiative citoyenne
alors l'idée qu'il soit en toute matière
c'est à dire qu' il soit constituant
camps puissent proposer une loi en
abrogé une et qu'on puisse faire
également qu'on puisse révoquer les élus
mais sur ses modalités d'application
ça reste à définir il ya des pistes on
peut ce
que ce que beaucoup de gens en tête
c'est faire d une pétition et établir un
seuil de signatures de pétitions on
parle on est autour de 700 milles où un
million de signatures pour effectivement
qui déclencherait le référendum mais
vous avez également des personnes qui
envisagent la création d'une ou
d'assemblées citoyennes qui seraient
tirés au sort et qui pourrait déclencher
le le référendum et puis vous avez
également des gens et à mon avis ça
c'est une piste très sérieuse explorer
qui propose qu'il y ait une plateforme
institutionnelle où chaque citoyen
s'inscrirait il y aura un contrôle de
l'identité évidemment etc et c'est par
ce biais là qu'on pourrait proposer
de déclencher des référendum c'est
notamment qu' il l'a développée chez
vous en plus olivier berruyer qui est à
une idée de dire qu'on créerait ce type
de plateforme et puis que sur l'année
les gens voteraient et puis à la fin on
retient les cinq ou dix propositions qui
ont été le plus massivement adoubé
et on le passerai au vote l'année
suivante bon donc voilà il ya des pistes
comme ça aujourd'hui alors je sais qu'il
ya des organisations à condé dispositif
plus plus fixé mais en l'état ça discute
sur sur les ronds-points dans les
réunions publiques on a des discussions
moi je crois que ya pas de formule
magique de toute façon pour avoir une
démocratie alors
il est pas question à mon sens de
remettre en cause le principe de la
démocratie représentative dans un pays
de 65 millions d'habitants vous avez pas
gouverner le pays un pays uniquement par
référendum je veux dire les gens vont
pas avoir envie de savoir si dans le
code de l'urbanisme
on va mettre la distance entre l'aele
trottoir à un mètre cinquante jours 1 m
80 je veux dire c'est pas ce qui compte
c'est de pouvoir donner les grandes
orientations et notamment par exemple le
référendum de 2005 qui a été trahie en
2008 avec le traité lisbonne ont massé
ça en fait qu'il faut permettre c'est
que les gens puissent sur ces grandes
questions où les gouvernants empêcher
que les gouvernants puces les trahir et
puis derrière
ça en revanche s'il ya des difficultés
qui se posent qu'il faut pas balayer
d'un revers de la main dans le cadre du
référendum d'initiative citoyenne ça
pose plein de questions en fait d'ordre
institutionnel et d'une manière générale
vous avez la question de l'éducation des
gens pour qu'ils aient un esprit
critique et vous avez question de
l'information des gens sur sur
l'éducation et
en lien avec l'information ça fait déjà
quand même 45 ans que on est donc
empoisonné par l'idéologie néolibérale
c'est à dire vous avez des gens beaucoup
qui sont dans le coma politique et qui
n'ont pas un esprit critique très
aiguisé
donc comment on fait déjà pour les
sortir de la torpeur et puis vous avez
ensuite le l'information et là en l'état
s'il ne réforme pas le traitement de
l'information aujourd'hui dans notre
pays je
vois pas bien à quoi va servir le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne parce
que vous avez de tels moyens de
manipulation de l'opinion publique qui
sont utilisés que ils arriveront ils ont
tout misé aurons de grandes chances
d'arriver toujours de toute façon nous
faire voter contre nos propres intérêts
donc question pour leurs efforts
médiatiques c'est
assez compliqué jeu il ya deux problèmes
majeurs a à mon sens à traiter je suis
pas spécialiste de la question inverse
les deux premiers c'est évidemment le
fait que neuf milliardaire détiennent
90% des médias traditionnels mais
donc comment on fait pour déconnecter
les puissances d'argent les très riches
avec la détention de ces médias mais
en fait c'est pas la seule explication
parce que je pense que chacun pourra
voir que le traitement de l'information
n'est pas bien meilleurs et même mais
parfois pire par le service public
notamment par france 2 donc
en réalité je pense qu'il ya une
explication qui est d'ordre sociologique
vous avez là des gens qui sont la classe
moyenne supérieure et duke est censé
être cultivée je pense qu'il y en a mais
pas tous et
qui en fait on ce réflexe de classe de
bourgeois c'est ce qui explique très
bien françois bégaudeau et qui ne
veulent pas de changement qui sont
verrouillés par la peur et donc qu'ils
font tout pour conserver l'ordre social
tel qu'il est établi aujourd'hui donc il
ya un énorme travail à faire
effectivement sur le sur le traitement
de l'information qui dont le problème
majeur aujourd'hui c'est qu'il il se
drape sous le sceau de l'objectivité
c'est notamment le monde ou même france
2 jean là explique qu'ils sont
impartiaux et objectifs alors que
l'objectivité intrinsèquement ne peut
pas exister chaque personne voilée voit
la réalité avec un son prisme et donc
subjectif et la seule chose à laquelle
on puisse entendre c'est vers
l'honnêteté intellectuelle et essayer de
créer de la contradiction il faut
absolument permettre la contradiction
dans le débat public sauf qu'aujourd'hui
on voit très bien que vous avez des
sujets qui sont totalement verrouillée
par les médias traditionnels dont on ne
peut pas débattre du kent l'euro
essayait de main de parler de l'euro et
on sait tout de suite les
accusations mais vous êtes fous tout le
monde dit que alors que tout le monde
sait les écoles et des éditorialistes
puis les prix nobel d'économie comme
joseph stiglitz milton friedman et puis
nos économistes français extrêmement
sérieux et compétent sur la question
comme jacques sapir notamment ceux là
sont totalement invisibilité il n'existe
pas et donc on préfère écouter des
éditorialistes qui a priori sont
beaucoup plus compétent sur ces
questions là en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
nous explique donc vous avez des sujets
centraux qui sont totalement verrouillé
et est en fait c'est le sait
ce qui défend l'idéologie néolibérale
idéologie néolibérale donc qui tient à
pas grand chose qui tient éveillé entre
dépenses publiques il faut la
compétitivité la flexibilité et cetera
on peut pas imposer les riches parce que
sinon ils partent il ya trop de
fonctionnaires vous voyez vous êtes
cadenassé par 6,7 c6 cette idée là et
puis terminé et ça ça a constitué la
prison idéologique puis ensuite la
prison des institutionnels ce sont les
traités européens actuellement c'est les
deux vont de pair et donc dès lors vous
toucher à ça quelques heures nucléaire
de la politique qui est qu'on subit
depuis des années là vous pouvez pas
débattre est ce que vous avez lu l'art
d'avoir toujours raison de arthur
schopenhauer
non j'ai lu récemment un livre de
schopenhauer mais je ne crois pas que ce
soit celui là il était le titre je sais
j'attendais je sais plus et oui ya six
mois je
serai pas vous dire certains lui quoi
c'était
assez intéressant vous aviez une une
critique effectivement des
hommes de bonne société et il expliqué
que selon lui les hommes les plus
intelligents ils sont voués à vivre seul
à s'isoler de plus en plus parce qu'ils
vont être déçus de plus en plus par par
la compagnie humaine et et les futilités
en fait de leur entourage et et donc il
expliquait sa notamment donc je me suis
dit que finalement si j'avais de moins
en moins d'amis s'étaient peut-être pas
c'était peut-être pas aussi connaissez
vous connaissez la même internet par
rapport à ça non ça avant d'être
dépressif vérifiez bien que vous êtes
pour tous rue pour une bande de connards
bon [rires]
moi j'essaye d'être bienveillant de
manière générale même avec mes amis dont
je suis totalement opposé à leurs idées
politiques mais je crois qu'il ya que
par la bienveillance quand on peut
arriver justement aller à les amener à
changer leurs opinions alors pendant que
l'équipement volés les questions
d'internet d'ailleurs on passe je suis
sûr qu'on va écouter sur certains
pendant ce moment on repasse un grand
coup et est ce que vous pouvez m'envoyer
les questions d'internet tu remontes la
liste tout en super donc on va en
prendre en piocher
quid agriculteurs qui sont dans une
situation désespérée et qui vont avoir
qui vont voir arriver des traités de
libre échange pour interrogation bon
c'est formulé à la fois que je te pousse
voulait
rebondir sur cette question là les
agriculteurs pourquoi ils bougent pas
ils sont tenus quand on voit à emmanuel
macron faire l'assistante sociale le
salon de l'agriculture avec une personne
âgée et le prendre son petit papier et
faire un peu comme louis xiv en disant
voilà je vais t'aider mon bon monsieur
dans ma grande mansuétude je suis
magnanime et je fais pleurer les
licornes et les bisounours et les
agriculteurs ils bougent parce qu'ils
croient ils sont tus par l'impact parce
que c'est les gros céréaliers parce que
quoi l épisode l'équipe tant mieux ils
sont jamais payés ils ont aucune
subvention et puis comment se réguler sa
17e cours et que les agriculteurs bouge
pas ouais je crois que vous avez déjà
répondu à ma place c'est à dire que bon
il ya évidemment la stratégie immonde de
communication du président de la
république en fait on aimerait bien que
ces gens-là arrête d'être des
communicants et qui se comporte enfin
comme des hommes politiques qui posent
des actes politiques et qui dirige le
pays et qu'ils insufflent des
changements et qu'ils arrêtent de
raisonner comme des comptables et qu'ils
soient en fait simplement là pour
assurer le service après-vente de bercy
et de la commission européenne bon sur
les agriculteurs oui
effectivement il ya la question de la
pac qui est aujourd'hui les tiens mais
il est évident que pour eux on ne les
sortira jamais la misère dans laquelle
ils peuvent être pour beaucoup d'entre
eux dans le cadre des traités de libre
échange c'est une évidence absolue
c'est la même logique quand j'expliquais
dans l'union européenne en laye grandes
multinationales qui délocalisent dans
les pays de l'est les agriculteurs si on
les met en concurrence nos agriculteurs
si on y met en concurrence avec des pays
qui ont des coûts de production très
inférieurs parce qu'en plus ils
respectent pas et ne respecte pas les
normes environnementales et sociales que
nous on à dire on ne résoudra jamais
rien donc il est évident que là ça
passera par une politique de
protectionnisme et de taxes pour
protéger nos secteurs stratégiques et
l'agriculture évidemment dans notre pays
c'est un secteur tout à fait stratégique
c'est stratégique dans le pays s'arrête
c'est tout le problème [grognement]
autre question d'internet est ce que ça
a changé quelque chose pour vous d'être
porte parole vous avez été fâché avec
vos amis votre famille est-ce que vous
avez déjà été approché par des partis
politiques dans la république en marche
la france insoumise j'ai cru entendre
que vous étiez proche de france
insoumise alors je
veux pas dire ce que j'ai voté au
premier tour parce que justement je la
tribune que j'ai aujourd'hui emportant
le gilet jaune je n'ai pas d'étiquette
et donc ça me permet justement que le
discours passe sans filtre et que les
gens écoutent les arguments c'est ce qui
est le coeur de la politique celle des
idées et donc après ils sont d'accord ou
pas d'accord mais au moins il écoute
parce que dès lors qu on vous classe
dans une case politique ça y est vous
êtes filtrer et donc si si quelqu'un qui
n'est pas deux bords politiques l'
écoute mais en fait il n'écoutera pas et
ne réfléchira même pas osé donc je veut
évidemment pas dire de quel bord
politique je suis ce qui est certain
c'est que j'ai jamais été membre d'un
parti politique j'ai jamais été membre
d'un syndicat donc j'ai jamais exercé de
fonction pour un parti jamais touché le
moindre euro de la part d'un parti
politique pour vous dire j'ai même j'ai
jamais même été déléguée de classe 1
toute ma scolarité certain que voilà
c'est vous dire quel était mon
engagement politique auparavant ça a
changé quelque chose de temporaire voire
dont j'ai des copines plus de copies non
non non vous savez je suis marié donc
donc voilà ça ça change pas et
et il ya six mois donc félicitations un
peu plus de six mois merci et auxquels
je rends canon oui tout à fait et non
j'ai pas du tout perdu d'amis alors je
les vois beaucoup moins ça c'est une
certitude parce que j'ai un peu pris par
le mouvement 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7 mais en revanche non
non tout le monde me soutient c'est à
dire que tout le monde c'est la
sincérité de mon engagement que là je me
force pas je défends mes convictions il
se trouve que mes convictions mais
j'essaie
de les mettre au service du mouvement
est en tout cas se confondent avec les
aspirations du mouvement donc c'est ce
que je fais mais non j'ai plutôt le
soutien y compris d'ailleurs aussi de la
plupart de mes confrères qui m'envoient
des messages de pour me dire qu'ils
approuvent effectivement mon action et
j'ai d'ailleurs profité de la tribune
qui m'était donné pour essayer de
médiatiser un peu la réforme de la
justice et des deux condamnés de
contester cette réforme parce qu'elle
s'inscrit en fait dans les aspirations
du mouvement à la défense des services
publics essentiels et donc la justice en
fait partie mais disons que non ça va
pas si ça a changé une chose là dans ma
vie en l'état c'est simplement que j'ai
quasiment plus de temps pour m'occuper
de mon cabinet et ça c'est un très gros
problème qui me cause énormément de
stress vous
avez une attachée de presse alors j'ai
pas g j'ai rencontré en fait je croyais
et mathieu lelièvre je les rencontre est
en fait le 1er décembre lors d'une
réunion qui était organisée à
l'initiative de r d'hervé morin qui est
le président de la région normandie et
qui avait réuni une
délégation de gilet jaune de divers
endroits de la région et donc on était
une quarantaine de gilet jaune de rouen
deux camps de la manche et c'est de
dieppe et
l'intérêt des premiers intérêts de la
réunion ça a été de qu'on a pu se mettre
tous en réseau du coup ce qu'on était
tous avaient isolé sur sur les
ronds-points alors on connaissait le
rond-point d'à côté mais on connaissait
pas le rond point qui était à 100 km ou
200 km ça nous a permis de nous mettre
en réseau et puis je suis resté en
contact avec plusieurs et notamment
sébastien lelièvre ce qui était
intéressant parce que on était chacun
gilet jaune des deux grandes villes de
normandie et donc on échangeait sur les
sur les actions sur les méthodes de
mobilisation qu'on utilisait de part et
d'autre et il se trouve que lui dans la
vie dans la vraie vie et en dehors du
mouvement des jeunes il est attaché de
presse dans la culture et donc quand
j'ai commencé à avoir des relations avec
les médias il m'a proposé de m'aider
bénévolement au même titre que je
m'engage bénévolement dans dans le
mouvement donc voilà comment c'est fait
autre
question internet vas-y tous un coup et
c'est [rires]
[toux][raclement de gorge]
bosser tes zik pas alors quel est votre
ennemi principal dans la lutte on
reconnaît un c je
dirais qu'il y en a deux il ya la
surdité du gouvernement
quand on a affaire à des gens qui ne
veulent pas nous entendre c'est à dire
que je vois beaucoup de gilet jaune qui
voudrait qu'on qu'on se structure qu'on
ait des porte parole nationaux etc mais
le problème c'est que ces gens là ne
veulent pas dialoguer ne veulent pas
négocier donc du
coup la seule manière de gagner c'est de
gagner le rapport de forces politiques
d'avoir un mouvement de masse qui est
vraiment investi les rues par la grève
le blocage de l'économie et a que ça qui
va permettre effectivement de gagner le
rapport de force politique et d'obliger
une fine et le pouvoir exécutif a cédé
et cd ça veut dire soit il change sa
politique radicalement soit y retournent
aux urnes donc je suis tout de suite sur
la question après que pensez-vous de la
grève générale ou l'organisent comment
parce que des projets de sabotage sont
évoquées sur les ronds-points alors
des opérations coup de poing il y en a
depuis le début alors elle était en tout
cas à rouen il ya eu très tôt un
rapprochement d'opportunités avec les
syndicats pour essayer de bloquer ici ou
là il ya eu blocage notamment du rubis
d'un dépôt de carburant en moins une
journée il ya eu comme ça diverses
opérations de blocage qui se sont
produites après comment on organise la
grève générale c'est le sens de l'appel
que nous avons lancé à
compter du 5 février
l'idée était de faire déjà une première
journée avec une mobilisation permettant
d'avoir les gilet jaune et les syndicats
sur le plan national c'est ce qui s'est
produit pour crée déjà des liens du
réseau et permettent de construire
ensuite un dialogue commun et et
construire les modalités de la grève
générale c'est très bien de saipan
claquant des doigts que va l'obtenir est
historiquement on sait qu'à priori on a
plus de chances d'y arriver au printemps
quand il fait beau que sous les
températures extrêmement froides donc en
fait l'objectif à terme on est en train
de viser le printemps les
forces de l'ordre pour voiliers sont
déjà sur les rotules non
mais on se bat aussi pour eux et je
crois qu'il y en a une bonne partie qui
le savent parce que pour avoir discuté
avec quelques-uns qui pouvaient venir
sur les ronds points hauts il nous le
disait en chuchotant mais mais mais il
son soutien [raclement de gorge] des
gilet jaune parce que ils savent très
bien qu'on se bat aussi pour eux l'autre
question internet comment comprenez vous
que toutes les revendications des gilet
jaune n'est pas trouvée d'expression
dans les élections je
crois en réalité que
le comment dirais-je vous avez des
partis d'oppostion ait un parti
d'opposition qui exprime une partie des
revendications notamment quand je parle
moi de la critique des traités européens
et a quand même plusieurs partis qui
font la critique de ces traités la
difficulté aurait en réalité aujourd'hui
qu'on a sur le plan politique et sur le
plan électoral
c'est que tous les partis souverainistes
et qui donc critique
les traités européens sont illiquides
c'est le front national france insoumise
dupont aignan acelino pour dire les
choses simplement sont éclatés et
avec les étiquettes médiatique qui leur
sont donnés extrême droite extrême
gauche je parle d'un couple autistes ou
carrément complotisme ans je parle quand
j'ai extrêmement hâte extrême gauche je
parlais de 2,2 des étiquettes qui
viennent du traitement médiatique moi je
sais pas trop ce que c'est extrêmement
aujourd'hui que j'aimerais bien qu'on
définisse ce que c'est mais s'est
éclatée et macro lui vampirise le centre
c'est ce qu'il a fait et c'est comme ça
qu'il a gagné les élections et c'est
comme ça qu'il espère regagner les
prochaines c'est en comptant sur les spl
aspects de division d de ces partis qui
partagent des idées communes notamment
sur le plan de la souveraineté mais qui
sont qui sont divisés d'hommes qui sont
faibles et qui du coup est bien c'est
sur ce plan là que prospère la stratégie
du président de la république donc voilà
pourquoi aujourd'hui on a on a ce
problème au niveau des élections qu'on
n'arrive pas à ce que les idées qui sont
portées
et bien prennent le pouvoir au niveau
institutionnel et je crois que c'est
l'opportunité peut-être du mouvement des
gilets jaunes que de d'insister sur les
points de convergence d'arriver à
fédérer tout le monde au delà des
étiquettes au delà des appartenances
partisanes droit de gauche il faut
arrêter avec droite gauche le sujet
aujourd'hui ses mondialistes contre
souverainiste c'est à dire anti
démocrates contre démocrate il faut
effectivement que ce soit les démocrates
qui gagne à la fin votre question
internet ici vous personnellement vous
aviez beaucoup d'argent que feriez-vous
différemment je
[raclement de gorge]
n'ai pas beaucoup d'argent donc je me
suis jamais posé la question je
crois de toute façon que les problèmes
qui sont posés dépasse largement ce
qu'on peut faire et une échelle
individuelle je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
ya que haut niveau a minima des états
que l'on peut arriver à impulser une
autre politique donc je
vois pas ce que ça changerait en fait
pas qu'à titre personnel j'ai voyagé
beaucoup d'argent aux
questions internet qui le régime
politique vous semble le plus adapté
cette
année dictature si votre sans hésiter un
petit
petit élections on
va dire quand
j'avais noté ça bougeait peu j'ai
retrouvé note donc le système politique
préférentielle c'est qu'on sait c'est on
reste dans le mouvement républicain moi
[grognement] je crois que effectivement
la
république et la démocratie c'est le
c'est le moins mauvais des systèmes à
des régimes politiques maintenant quand
on voit le résultat actuel il est
évident qu'il va falloir la forme des
institutions et là la
réforme gf primordial impérieuse c'est
de réinstaurer du contrôle citoyen
vis-à-vis de nos gouvernants en
fait la constitution qui a été fait sur
mesure par et pour le général de gaulle
ne prévoyait pas de garde-fou c'était
pas grave puisque le général de gaulle
s'appliquer lui-même cette discipline et
ce sens de la démocratie en remettant en
cause son mandat lorsque c'était
nécessaire et il n'a jamais considéré
qu'il avait un blanc-seing donc pour
pour mener la politique que bon lui
semblait le problème c'est que une fois
qu'il est parti sa pratique n'a jamais
été reprise par les suivants est donc
aujourd'hui on a un vide au niveau
constitutionnel puisqu'on n'a pas
institutionnaliser et bien ce
comportement démocratique à savoir que
quand vous n'avez plus d'adhésions
majoritaire à la politique que vous
voulez mener et vous partez tout
simplement et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans le cadre du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne il ya cette
question notamment du référendum
révocatoire pour pouvoir contrôler les
élus et quand ils nous trahissent ou qui
font vraiment n'importe quoi on pourra
révoquer leur mandat mais le simple fait
déjà d'introduire ce contrôle moralisera
mon ami très vite leur comportement et
ils feront au moins pâle inverse des
camps et des promesses qu'ils avaient pu
faire pendant leur campagne électorale
donc si je sentais 6 trivialement vous
demander plus de flexibilité ou près des
élus n'ont
plus de sincérité et d'honnêteté je
crois qu'aujourd'hui la la la la
difficulté c'est que ces gens-là ne
poursuive plus l'intérêt général mais
simplement les intérêts particuliers de
quelques privilégiés privilégiés qui
d'ailleurs financent leurs campagnes
électorales donc vous avez des
gouvernants qui se retrouvent dans la
main à la base de ceux qui les ont
financés et donc vous avez un retour
d'ascenseur qui intervient donc il ya de
toute façon
en fait il n'ya pas il n'y a pas un
régime parfait il n'y a pas une formule
magique mais en revanche aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'il ya un certain nombre de
points sur lesquels il faut agir et
peut-être dire un mot de la proposition
julia cagé que j'ai découvert récemment
sur la méthode de financement des
campagnes électorales et qui prévoit est
qui et qui prévoit je dirais manière
assez intelligente fort et je
m'intéresse plus mais j'ai compris dans
l'idée que on permettrait plus à des
très riches de financer la campagne
électorale sachant qu'en l'état ces très
riches ont un crédit d'impôt à hauteur
de deux tiers dans le dans les
financements qu'ils accordent donc
embêté par nos impôts qu'on finance le
fait que les riches financent là quand
elle les campagne électorale donc c'est
quand même grandiose donc là on aurait
dans sa proposition schématiquement et
j'espère je défends pas trop sa pensée
mais vous auriez des bons en réalité qui
seraient accordées à chaque citoyen est
donc chaque chaque citoyen chaque année
des 6 dreads à corner cette enveloppe à
tel ou tel parti ou une question
d'internet comment recréer un lien entre
les classes populaires les classes
populaires et des classes moyennes alors
je crois que le lien il existe déjà
entre les classes populaires et classes
moyennes je crois qu'il est brisée en
revanche entre classes populaires
classes moyennes et les classes moyennes
supérieures je crois que là la fracture
aujourd'hui elle est là c'est à dire les
gens qui ont fait des études supérieures
et qui ceux qui se sentent bourgeois qui
se pensent bourgeois et qui se pensent
plus proche de l'oligarchie de la haute
bourgeoisie que des gens qui sont en
dessous d'eux et qu'ils vivent avec le
rêve de pouvoir accéder aussi peut-être
à la haute bourgeoisie et comment on
fait est tout simplement c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure à ces gens là sont
dans le déni ils ne veulent pas voir la
misère qui est autour d'eux et en fait
ils vivent dans leur petit confort
individuel ils travaillent et gagnent
bien leur vie et donc le samedi y
consomment ils font les magasins ils
font leurs activités et puis tout va
bien pour eux donc ils n'ont pas à se
poser ces questions et je crois donc il
ya un premier levier c'est mais
insuffisant mais c'est d'essayer de par
l'argumentation leur expliquer que une
autre politique est possible et que
cette autre politique ne viendrait pas
les appauvrir parce que le premier
réflexe c'est quand même ça c'est
certain mais si ça changeait ce que moi
je vais pas y perdre je pense qu il il
ya ce premier point de blocage il faut
il faut bien qu'ils comprennent
qu'aujourd'hui un changement de
politique c'est pas à les taxer plus les
gens qui gagnent cinq dix ou quinze
mille euros par mois pas ces gens là qui
sont visés et c'est quand même dix ou
quinze mille euros par mois c'est une
somme essayez les classes moyennes
supérieures provincial prem's et ceux
qui gagnent sans milou un million par
mois et le deuxième levier peut-être
c'est d'agir sur l'émotion je pense
qu'il faut arriver à recréer de
l'empathie est donc là leur montrer
concrètement peut-être par la culture et
l'art la misère aujourd'hui profonde qui
est vécu par les classes populaires est
ce que ces fameuses août étude n'a pas
conduit à sélectionner les gens les plus
dangereux certainement
parce que effectivement on sait très
bien que la réussite scolaire est
souvent donnée aux gens qui sont les
plus conformistes qui s'inscrivent plus
dans le cadre dans le moule et donc vu
mais oui certainement et elle est plus
discipliné et et
qu'effectivement ils poursuivent un
schéma établi et ils ont du mal à sortir
le rôle de leur boîte ils ont du mal à
se remettre en question et à remettre en
question l'ordre établi et ça c'est une
difficulté parce qu'ils sont dans un
comportement moutonnier et quand le
système qui est en place conduit à une
fragmentation de la société et une
explosion des tensions il faut être
capable de remise en question il faut
être capable d'autocritique et ceux qui
ont réussi scolairement c'est peut-être
pas les plus disposés justement armes et
à se remettre en question et à faire son
autocritique
autre
question d'internet est ce que vous êtes
en contact avec d'autres mouvements à
l'étranger non pour ma part une autre
question internet les parlementaires
doivent-ils tiré au sort 2
2 merci des parlementaires doivent-ils
être tiré au sort pour représenter le
peuple alors moi je suis confiant je
sais réservé sur cette question là j'ai
pas d'avis définitif
je vois bien l'intérêt tout de suite
qu'il y aurait à tirer au sort c'est
justement
un moyen de déconnecter le les
puissances d'argent avec avec les élus
et donc ne plus permettre aux riches de
financer les campagnes électorales on
aurait des gens tirent au sort donc par
définition des gens lambda et je dirais
libéré de toute emprise de telles ou
telles puissances d'argent le problème
évidemment qui se pose derrière c'est la
question de la compétence des personnes
et rédiger des lois c'est quand même
c'est quand même compliqué moi je le
vois mon niveau dans ma pratique
professionnelle vous avez les
juridictions prud'homales et donc vous
avez des salariés ou d ampleur qui sont
élus et qui sont amenées à statuer en
matière de droit du travail et au début
de leur mandat c'est quand même très
compliqué parce que ils n'ont pas une
formation en droit et donc ils sont
assez désemparé pour juger véritablement
endroits des dossiers donc c'est une
haie ce sont des matières complexe en
revanche je crois que une bonne idée
c'est que le tirage au sort puisse
permettre peut-être de créer une ou des
assemblées citoyennes qui contrôlerait
les élus qui est donc pas élus par
définition des gens qui eux seraient nos
représentants mais issu du suffrage et
il ya un équilibre à trouver de toute
façon pour pour faire en sorte que la
politique qui est menée et soit
déconnectée des intérêts financiers des
lobbys des puissances d'argent je vous
dis torrenté je remercie
les 5900 personnes qui sont en ce moment
en direct avec nous et j'en profite pour
passer une autre question internet que
pensez vous de la liste citoyenne pour
les municipales moi
je suis assez comme je voulais dit
opposé
aussi aux municipales enfin aujourd'hui
pour moi les seules élections et qui
peuvent permettre de changer la
politique dans ce pays c'est ce sont les
présidentielles et les législatives
et donc je crois pas que
enfin ça se joue pas au niveau municipal
tant que vous allez vous avez pas remis
en cause le cadre national et le cadre
européen vous pouvez pas changer la
politique donc c'est pas au niveau
municipal que que quand on va pouvoir
améliorer la vie des gens question
plusieurs entrées plein emploi écologie
pour interrogation pouvoir d'achat
écologie pour interrogation comment
est-ce que c'est conciliables très
simplement il
faut pu viser la croissance on ne peut
plus viser la croissance des enfants
alors ça serait évidemment un gros
problème qui se pose effectivement
l'aspect démographique mais on ne peut
plus viser mais en l'état dans nos pays
développés on est plutôt à 2 voire en
dessous de 2 dans nos pays développés on
est plutôt en décroissance sur le plan
démographique on
ne peut plus viser la croissance mais en
revanche on peut tout à fait faire
du travail en plus on en a besoin pas
forcément du travail qui crée de la
pollution vous avez besoin notamment de
beaucoup plus de personnes qui
travaillent dans les services d'aidé à
la personne pour les personnes âgées là
vous avez pas d activité industrielle
qui vont augmenter
le pib mais en revanche cela vous ne
créez du travail qui est utile à la
société et puis ensuite vous
avez évidemment un moment donné il
question qui va se poser qui est celle
bien de l'évolution technologique qui se
posent déjà depuis des années et du
remplacement du travail de l'homme par
la machine est
donc le but c'est que ce que la machine
fait à la place de l'homme servent à
améliorer justement le quotidien de tout
le monde et donc la visée in fine et
c'est que la machine puisse permettre à
l'homme de se dégager de plus en plus de
temps de travail disponible et donc
venir baisser le temps de travail alors
ça je ne dis pas que c'est une mesure
qui en l'état actuel des choses pour
être appliqué il faudrait déjà remettre
les choses en ordre mais quand on
commence effectivement à essayer de
trouver les incompatibilités entre plein
emploi et écologie je pense que ce sont
ces pistes là qu'il va falloir mettre en
oeuvre autre question internet
cette expérience vous donne-t-elle envie
de devenir un professionnel de la
politique alors
très concrètement je ne sais absolument
pas ce que je ferai pour tout vous dire
dans le cadre du mouvement je sais pas
où j'en serai dans deux semaines ou dans
un mois ce que je sais c'est que je
mènerai le combat politique d'une
manière ou d'une autre je ne sais pas
sous quelle forme mais il est évident
que c'est quelque chose qui est
profondément ancrée en moi que j'ai des
convictions j'ai un objectif qui est de
la politique change enfin dans notre
pays sous quelle forme je sais pas
j'irai j'irai là où c'est le plus
efficace vous allez vous vous aller
grossir le rang des partis politiques
juste après en fait non jb bruit c'est
tout ce que je vous dis justement jeu
peut-être que si si les six je suis le
plus efficace en présentant suffrages
peut-être que je ferai ça mais souffre
âges à partir d'un parti politique qui
voudrait mais justement tout dépendra
des conditions déjà c'est à dire que un
parti politique actuelle moi je veux
défendre mes convictions j'ai pas envie
de
voyez de faire des contorsions et
d'avoir à faire des contorsions à
renoncer à certaines de mes convictions
donc ce sera peut-être pas possible est
ce que ce sera sur la base d'un parti
politique créé sur la base du mouvement
des gilet jaune est ce que c'est
possible est-ce que les gens voudront ça
pas sûr si les conditions sont pas
réunies j'irai peut-être jamais au
suffrage et je mènerai le combat sur le
terrain des idées l'émancipation des
constant des consciences et donc
peut-être que j'écrirais le livre que
j'avais commencé à écrire deux mois
avant le début du mouvement et que
j'avais projeté d'appeler le réveil
citoyen peut-être que j'écrirais ce
livre là peut-être que j'essaierai de
faire une chaîne youtube pour faire de
l'éducation populaire enfin je sais que
je je je mènerai le combat politique
celui des idées de l'émancipation des
consciences sous quelle forme j'en ai
aucune idée je n'exclus rien mais ce qui
est certain c'est que je veux rester
fidèle et sincère à mes convictions
grève de la faim je
suis pas certain que par la grève de la
faim en obtiennent en obtiennent des
résultats malheureusement quand on voit
qu'aujourd'hui on vous avez vous voulez
pas devenir martyr pour le gilet jaune
que ce catalyseur qui peut citer aussi
guéris à regarder il ya mon ami jérôme
rodriguez qui a perdu un oeil et et pour
autant pouvoir exécutif n'a pas bougé
d'un pouce sainte-catherine
d'orge oui
bien sûr mais je crois que il n'y a pas
que ça qui qui fait que j'ai remonté
guess a beaucoup de soutien je crois que
c'est quelqu'un qui tient une ligne bah
oui oui mais pas seulement c'est enfin
il a beaucoup de répartie sur les
plateaux de télévision il connaît des
choses et effectivement il se débrouille
vraiment très bien et il sert vraiment à
la cause du mouvement et il est sincère
et par dessus tout il est sincère et il
sert le collectif
autre question d'internet si vous
travaillez plus dans votre cabinet
d'avocats vous faisiez vous vite quoi ah
bah actuellement je vis sur les réserves
c'est à dire que j'ai une chance ou sais
c'est que quand
vous êtes libérés libéral les impôts on
n'est pas trop pendant un pote
d'imposition actuellement ça va
commencer au mois de mai pour l'instant
en fait je vis de la trésorerie que
que j'ai là sur mon compte professionnel
qui est en train de fondre petit à petit
et donc à un moment donné va falloir que
je effectivement je relance la machine
parce que ça fait de compter en rouge du
personnel ça nous menons ah oui bien sûr
non mais c'est de toute façon ces décès
de ensuite cessé des revenus qui sont
imposés une façon je suis à titre
individuel j'ai pas de société un an que
c'est tout à fait transparent non
professionnel est imposé mais disons
dans le calendrier fiscal et en termes
de cotisations sociales les prélèvements
commence plus tôt à partir du mois de
mai donc là vous voyez je peux encore
vivre un peu j'ai un peu de marge de
trésorerie mais il va pas falloir que ça
dure encore des mois et des mois parce
que en ou en tout cas il va falloir que
je reprenne un peu de temps et c'est ce
que je compte faire d'ailleurs là et
c'est de reprendre un peu de temps pour
pour travailler à mon cabinet et puis
notamment faire les dossiers que je doit
urgemment traité pour mclain cultive de
dossiers vous traitez en ce moment j'ai
des dossiers de droit du travail donc je
représente plutôt des salariés contre
contre des entreprises dans le cadre de
de licenciement qui l'ont dont ils ont
fait l'objet ggd
dossier je vous dis de droit commercial
de de droit immobilier voilà je suis
plutôt généraliste en fait mais je ne
fais pas de droit pénal pas de droit
fiscal et pas droit administratif est
ce que vous voyez un sujet que vous les
abordez aux particuliers peut-être
oui aborder
la question de la dérive autoritaire de
du pays parce que ça me semble
extrêmement préoccupants comme
d'habitude emmanuel todd avait été un
peu prophète j'avais vu une conférence
qui avait fait le 4 octobre 2018 et où
il parlait de cette dérive et un mois et
demi plus tard éclate le mouvement on a
une répression policière et judiciaire
qui est absolument mais incroyable
incroyable
les répressions et la répression
policière on en a parlé avec le nombre
de blessés on a deux mille blessés parmi
les manifestants
1200 blessés parmi les forces de l'ordre
et
plus d'une centaine de manifestantes
étaient mutilés éborgné et pourtant il
n'y a aucune conséquence politique il
n'ya pas un ministre qui a démissionné
un
thé tout ça est absolument sidérant vous
avez une répression judiciaire avec des
condamnations qui sont prononcés qui
sont est tout à fait exorbitante de ce
qu'on a soi qu'on assiste dans
le droit commun de manière habituelle
vous avez des procédures qui sont
diligentées par les parquets donc lé
procureur de la république qui ne sont
pas indépendants dans notre pays et ça
c'est un fait acquis puisque la france
il ya une décision la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme en 2009 des
consignes pour accélérer les procédures
faire des comparutions immédiates pour
que les gens soient condamnés le plus
vite possible et le plus sévèrement
possible et ça on en a eu les
révélations notamment par le canard
enchaîné qui donne d où le parquet de
paris donne des consignes illégale aux
officiers de police judiciaire pour
garder les gens en garde à vue quand on
ira même les dossiers sont totalement
vide vous avez une dérive à ce niveau là
vous avez ensuite la loi anti casseurs
alors là qui est une loi liberticide
mais extrêmement dangereuse dire charles
de courson qui est un député républicain
plutôt modéré quand même habituellement
et qui compte tenu de son histoire
personnelle a pesé ses mots a qualifé
cette loi de renvoi au régime de vichy
et je crois véritablement que les mots
ne sont pas exagérés parce que quand
vous confier le pouvoir à une autorité
administrative en l'occurrence le préfet
qui dépend directement du président de
la république d'interdire
à des personnes préventivement de
manifester c'est extrêmement liberticide
c'est une atteinte absolue à une liberté
fondamentale celle de s'exprimer la
liberté d'expression et quand vous
portez une atteinte à une liberté
fondamentale ça doit évidemment se
passait dans le cadre d un procès sur
l'autorité d'un magistrat indépendant
c'est-à-dire judiciaire parce que son
gars entier alors la représentation par
un conseil et surtout les droits de la
défense et un débat contradictoire là ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que si
c'est le préfet qui vous interdit ils
demandent rien à personne vous pouvez
pas vous défendre vous n'avez pas de
débat contradictoire on ne pouvait pas
présenter d'arc et on va vous interdire
de manifester charge à vous ensuite
d'aller contester ce que c'est ça ou
rien mais vous pouvez contester est
d'accord mais en attendant déjà vous
pouvez pas aller manifester parce qu'on
se doute bien dorée stratégie on va
prononcer l'interdiction de vendredi
soir pour que dès le lendemain donc à la
veille de la manifestation et puis
contester ça veut dire procédures ça
veut dire un avocat ça veut dire que il
faut il faut payer toi qui évidemment
ces
gens là qu'ils font passer cette loi là
savent très bien en fait ils vont
pouvoir comme ça empêcher à interdire
toute une série de manier de
manifestants qui devront pas les moyens
concrètement et bien de faire annuler
les décisions administratives qui
seraient prises à leur encontre autre
[soupir][souffle coupé]
question internet où on veut la pose est
quand même celle ci mais même si c'est
pas dans votre cas de qualification le
dérèglement climatique est totalement
ignorée par les gouvernements pourtant
toute la population va en souffrir un
peu cher à moi effectivement je suis pas
spécialisé sur la question mais s'il ya
une chose que j'ai comprise c'est que
tant qu'on reste dans le système actuel
où on explique que c'est laid connu une
marche et qui est règlement de tous qui
régit tous et que la politique au sens
noble ne peut pas soumettre l'économie
de marché à sa volonté on va dans le mur
c'est une absolue certitude c'est à dire
que tant qu' on ne ne se donne pas le
pouvoir de réguler effectivement les
activités économiques pour interdire ou
au moins pénaliser fiscalement les
activités qui sont polluantes des
activités qui sont en train de détruire
la planète et pour encore au contraire
encourager celles qui sont vertueuses il
est certain qu'on ne sortira jamais de
l'impasse et quand on entend le
président a un public qui lui fait une
conférence pour nous expliquer qu'on va
s'appuyer sur la finance pour opérer la
transition écologique on est dans le
délire le plus complet la finance c'est
l'origine du mal c'est
une logique court termisme court
termiste on est sur des opérations qui
se font à la nanoseconde
enfin c'est la quintessence de la
poursuite de l'intérêt individuel
immédiat et donc c'est tout l'inversé de
l'écologie qui nécessite d'avoir une
vision à long terme et qui vise
l'intérêt général donc là vous avez une
contradiction même total absolu et donc
c'est pas sur la finance qu'on pourra
s'appuyer c'est uniquement sur la
délibération collective et aurélien
barrau le dis encore plus clair dans
quoi autre
question y at il des groupes de vous
cagibi jaune comme blanc de nuit debout
avec les avocats debout alors
il y a il ya aujourd'hui non il ya je
crois pas à ma connaissance et je n'ai
pas il n'y a pas de collectif d'avocats
qui son gilet jaune j'avoue
que je je connais moi certains de leurs
confrères qui donc m'ont apporté leur
soutien mais qui sont mobilisés
effectivement qui sont allés sur les
ronds-points ou qui participent
effectivement une manifestation il y en
a quelques-uns mais il n'y a pas de
collectif ce que vous avez cédé
collectif d'avocats mais qui restent
dans leur exercice de leur pratique
professionnelle et qui se sont
constitués pour défendre les gilet jaune
et vous n'avez pas en revanche je me
semble-t-il à ma connaissance de deux
confrères organisé dans le cas d'un
collectif gilet jaune voulu
qu'on continue sur les violences
policières sur le parquet aux ordres de
l'état du monde jours du président
bah je crois que là-dessus j'ai dit à
peu près ce qu'il avait à dire après moi
je fais pas de droit pénal donc après je
ne peux pas plus poussées sur j'ai pas
eu de dossier par exemple moi je n'ai
pas défendu gilet jaune sur le plan
pénal puisque je ne sais pas faire je
suis pas compétent pour faire ça et donc
j'ai orienté vers tel ou tel de mes
confrères pour que pour que mes
collègues des zones soient bien
représenter efficacement représenté
en revanche peut-être précisé sera
dérive autoritaire que il ya eu un fait
incroyable qui a été traitée alors dans
les médias traditionnels manière à peine
surprenante mais la tentative de
perquisitions dans les locaux de
mediapart fitch
cia taclant pour faute grave de l'état
ouais c'est vrai qu'ils ont raison la
d'utiliser tous les moyens possibles et
imaginables parce que porter
une telle atteinte à la liberté la
presse et au secret des sources au motif
de l'atteinte à la liberté prix à la vie
privé d'alexandre benalla enfin là on
nage en plein délire à dire c'est
absolument incroyable alors qu'en plus
on sait très bien que juridiquement ça
peut pas tenir puisque les révélations
qui ont été faites sont fondées et ont
permis de notamment d'établir que avec
santana a violé son contrôle judiciaire
et c'est justement ce qui l'a conduit là
est placé en détention provisoire donc
ces informations là était d'intérêt
public et donc par conséquent le motif
d'atteinte à la vie privée ne tient
absolument pas et j'ai été très surpris
de voir comment les médias traditionnels
ont traité d'information c'est à dire
que au lieu de s'insurger de cette
procédure d'évidence illégal ou en tout
cas attentatoire à une liberté
fondamentale la liberté de la presse et
le secret des sources vous
aviez titre et mediapart refuse une
perquisition dans ses locaux c'est à
dire du coup le réflexe que vous avez
c'est de vous dira mais est ce que
mediapart était légitime a refusé la
perquisition voilà comment et quand ils
ont tourné d'information moi j'espérais
une
une profession des journalistes vent
debout pour une fois leur esprit
corporatiste aurait été bien placé pour
défendre mediapart je ne produis pas en
fait la réaction de jean-michel aphatie
qui dit voilà on voudrait savoir qui a
sonorisé un appartement et
donc vous comprenez pas ces réactions
bat pour connaître pas personnellement
mais le personnage il est quand même
plutôt disposé à toujours défendre le
pouvoir en place donc ça ne m'étonne pas
mais en revanche je suis en
contradiction totale effectivement avec
ses interrogations portent que sur le
plan juridique y en a pas aidés font pas
tout le temps pouvoir en place ah bon
j'ai un peu le jeu 8 quand
je dis le pouvoir en place en tout cas
c'est toujours les tenants de
l'idéologie néolibérale les traités
européens
j'ai jamais vu jean michel aphatie
critiquer l'euro ou là le pacte de
stabilité budgétaire européen on va lui
proposer un de ses cadres de venir sur
notre fauteuil de petitjean bibi
national jean 12h01 si tu nous écoutes
on arrive est-ce que vous avez trois
livres a conseillé à nos auditeurs à
notre communauté je vous laisse
réfléchir deux secondes et je place un
message n'oubliez pas de mousse bien sûr
tipi on a vraiment besoin de vous mais
indépendant grâce à vous votre
livre alors dans
les temps présents 1984
de george orwell je crois que c'est un
classique mais c'est une évidence
personnellement
moi j'ai lu un livre qui m'a apporté
certains livres de développement
personnel alors je sais que c'est à la
mode etc mais avec que j'ai trouvé
intéressante de stephen covey s'appelle
les cette habitude de ceux qui réalisent
tout ce qu'ils entreprennent alors
derrière le titre a un peu managériale
business en réalité c'est c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un livre qui permet de se
remettre
en question 2 et 2 de terrains et de
déterminer véritablement ce qu'on veut
faire dans la vie ce qu'on veut réaliser
et donc d'être très en phase et
avec ce qu'on est ce qu on veut être et
les mariages
ce
qu'on voudra réaliser une fine et on est
tranquille pour prendre des décisions
d'être serein quand on prend une
décision et quand on est face à des
choix difficiles 3e 3e
âge
et lieu sur le plan économique zee
economics la bd qui est assez
intéressante qui donne beaucoup
d'arguments sur sur justement la
critique notamment du libre échange et
puis ça ça réveille aussi beaucoup sur
les les
théories qui sont habituellement
attribuée notamment à adam smith la main
invisible et le fait que les intérêts
individuels convergeraient naturellement
vers l'intérêt général et en fait on
apprend dans la bd que adam smith il
n'était pas si libéral que ça et qu'en
fait il y avait des conditions pour que
la
libre concurrence fonctionne
effectivement de manière saine donc
cette bd là et elle est vraiment
intéressante est très bien fait avant de
vous poser ou vous demandez là le
conseil pour le dune les jeunes
générations vous connaissez la chaîne
youtube vous m'avez dit on
indique à d'autres communautés qu'on va
recevoir tout de suite après vous
francis dupuis déri qui est à
l'université québécois est en fait les
on a fait venir juste après vous parce
que les sujets qu'on va aborder sont
profondément interconnecté avec ce que
vous avez c'était
évoqué pendant l'interview si vous aviez
un conseil à laisser aux jeunes
générations bouteille
à la mer quelque chose d'un périssables
je me sens assez mal placé parce que
j'ai 32 ans je suis prêt tout à fait
dans la position du sage qui
al'expérience levé que je vous sens
l'idée je mens c'est vrai mais
aujourd'hui vont a priori je suis un âge
encore assez jeune je
crois qu'il faut il
faut essayer effectivement de tout le
temps se remettent en question et
de s'indigner 1 c c'était le livre de
stéphane hessel indignez-vous mais il
faut jamais accepter les choses telles
qu'elles sont et essayait toujours de
regarder les choses en face et
aujourd'hui on voit qu'on est par
le biais de la société de consommation
on n'a plus de sens en fait aujourd'hui
dans notre société on ne trouve plus de
sens et on le voit avec eux beaucoup
d'éduquer super rigueur qui était
destiné décalé dans la finance qui au
bout d'un moment abandonne cette
carrière et puis deviennent boulangers
pâtissiers ou menuisier et je crois que
véritablement il il faut essayer de
redonner du sens il faut toujours
essayer de naissance est en fait les
vraies valeurs intemporelles à mon avis
c'est l'amour le partage et la
fraternité c'est que dans le cadre des
reines du rapport aux autres et et des
liens qu'on peut tisser qu'on peut
véritablement essayer
d'être heureux france au boulou merci
merci à vous
[musique]